e
all right uh good morning um this is the
house uh Judiciary Committee we're going
to uh commence hearings on a number of
bills but before we do that would you
Allegiance Pledge of Allegiance to the
flag of the United States of America and
all right um before we get started I
just want to uh let the the audience
know that um we have uh several of us on
this committee have another bill that is
being heard in the Senate that we um uh
need to testify about so we may be
excusing oursel um at some point um
during the hearing and we apologize for
that but it can't be helped so um that's
where we are so with that I'm going to
open the hearing on uh Senate Bill
413 uh relative to civil actions for p
contamination
and I will recognize ah Senator
well good morning chairman Lynn and
members of the committee um Senator
Denise Rashard representing District 9
stretching from Bedford all the way to
Hinsdale uh clean water is an issue
that's incredibly important to me and
I've made it a priority to expand access
to clean water for families in my
district in across New Hampshire and one
of the greatest challenges is the past
contamination
and as I've start as we started testing
for these hazardous forever chemicals we
were finding that thousands of Granite
State families are at risk Property
Owners throughout the state including
residents schools businesses and other
entities have been impacted by the pfest
drinking water contamination in excess
of the MCL set forth in RSA
485116 the installation of drinking
water treatment systems or connection to
public water Supply is so necessary to
prevent consumption of drinking water at
unhealthful pfast
levels a party with significant greater
financial resources than an impacted
property owner has typically caused or
substantially contributed to the cause
of the pfest drinking water
contamination a property owner's cost of
Legally establishing responsibility for
contamination equals or exceeds the cost
of remediation through the installation
and maintenance of a point of Entry
treatment system known as poet or
connection to a public water supply as a
consequence of the resulting economic
Advantage a responsible party typically
has the financial burden of remedying
these PS contaminated uh drinking water
and is inequitably shifted from
responsible parties onto the
non-responsible parties including
property owners and public or public
remediation funding sources in addition
the time required to affect a remedy
results in prolonged unhealthful
exposure to past compounds this
situation requires a remedy to safeguard
the rights of property owners and to
protect and preserve the quality and
supply of drinking water in New
Hampshire that citizens in New Hampshire
rely on while we've dedicated millions
of dollars to connecting these families
to Reliable supplies of clean water it's
been difficult to hold polluters
responsible for the cleanup efforts
Senate Bill 4113 would create strict
liability for the contaminant cleanup
restoration or other remediation related
to the release or threatened release of
hazardous waste or hazardous material in
accordance with applicable law and
departmental rules and authorize the
Attorney General to Institute a civil
action so that we can recover the cost
from the people for the that is for the
people that are responsible for the
pollution Senate Bill fourth 13 would
also hold the individuals running pfest
facilities personally responsible for
clearing up pest contamination I do want
to thank the Department of Environmental
Services and the Attorney General's
office for helping craft this very
important legislation it holds the
polluters accountable and gets resources
we need to clean up pest in New
Hampshire now just to elaborate on that
this bill was a heavy lift and we went
through rigorous amend amendments making
sure that we are holding the true big
company responsible we know that there's
pest in everything we know there's pfest
at the hospital the way this bill is
structured it it doesn't include those
levels this is for the most stringent
polluter say like for instance St gobain
so um in collaborating with uh all the
stakeholders and the Business Institute
and industry Bia um they actually were
opposed until it was amended properly to
protect some of the small businesses
this is not about going after somebody
who unknowingly has the pest or the tiny
restaurant or the hospital either
everywhere this is about like the
situation that happened with st gobain
where um when the state made the decree
unknowingly they didn't realize it would
only be on like this side of 101 where
that part of marac and that part of
Bedford but now we know it's not just
run through the ground it's airborne and
now we have all this other contamination
so that all being said um everyone has
uh been in favor of this bill um and all
objections have been met so I really
hope that you can consider passing this
bill so that we can help the people in
the granite state and I'd be happy to
answer any
questions thank you very much questions
for this Witness
please good morning Senator good morning
um can you uh tell me uh if there is any
relationship between this bill and the
um the recent uh decisions that have
been made at the federal government
about uh addressing pest well that
decision came out after this bill had
passed the full body of the Senate so we
would still need need this bill because
we still are in a predicament um with
the we have like two main big polluters
in New Hampshire and they're not being
residents other questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
thank you so much for having me have a
wonderful day you also um next I'm going
to call on uh Mike whims
please oh and you know what senat
Senator Senator you know what could I
just ask you to fill out a a pink card
when you get a second thank thank you I
appreciate
that good morning Mr chair um members of
the committee uh for the record my name
is Mike whims I serve as director of the
waste management division for the New
Hampshire Department of Environmental
Services uh pleased to have the
opportunity to be before you to testify
in support of House of Senate Bill 413
so as as sponsor Senator rardy has
indicated that this the primary uh
effect of this bill is to establish a
private right of action for persons
whose drinking water well has been
impacted by uh releases from a p by
pasas contamination from a pasas
facility uh the secondary things that it
the bill does is to clarify some of the
liability provisions of RSA 147b uh
relative to persons who cause a release
of either hazardous material or a
hazardous waste um and again we do
support this bill as amended by the by
the by the Senate um so to provide a
little detail on that um section seven
the primary purpose here if the owner
operator of a past facility contaminates
water groundwater anywhere um or surface
water anywhere at great at a
concentration greater than 10,000 parts
per trillion um of a regulated compound
and we currently regulate uh four
different compounds um then the
liability then that party is liable
under this bill to provide safe clean
water to the impacted property owner and
that can take the form if they're lucky
enough to be located within a reasonable
distance from a water line it can be in
the form of connecting to a public water
system and with a waterline connection
or failing that to Prov provide them
with a point of entry treatment system
and and and and to then provide for the
ongoing operation and maintenance of
that system um so that's the primary
focus I think what really Senator was
trying to do with this bill um some of
the secondary things that happen here so
in section five that affirms that the
owner or operator of past facilities who
cause contamination greater than 10,000
parts per trillion are subject to the
liability provisions of RSA 147b the
hazard was clean of fund Act and then
section three clarifies that any person
who is responsible for release of any
hazardous material or hazardous waste um
is liable not just for costs but also to
conduct the containment the cleanup the
remediation and restoration that are
needed to address that
contamination and then section four of
the bill clarifies the Attorney
General's Authority uh to not only
recover costs but also to compel those
responses um and clean up so these
Provisions um State also that the
authority applies to any person um it
just makes some CL really what amount to
clarifications of the existing law in
RSA 147b and with that um that that's my
testimony I'll be happy to take any
questions question uh representative
Smith thank you um are are you
um are you saying that all Public Water
Systems in the state
um meet necessary standards in terms of
PS cont the lack of P contamination uh
no no I'm not I'm not saying that at all
there are um there are many public water
systems that um have already been found
to be over the standards that we
currently enforce for both for we have
state drinking water maximum contaminate
levels um the the one that most people
are familiar with is pfoa which has been
the primary contamin in Southern New
Hampshire and um there were a number of
water systems that were impacted by that
and in other places and those systems
have had to put on carbon treatment to
treat those that water so that it meets
the standard um to get to a question you
asked the senator about this recent
announcement EPA has recently announced
that they will now regulate um among
other contaminants pfoa and pfos at four
parts per trillion and the the result of
that is that there are going to be
probably on the order of another 150 to
200 Public Water Systems that will now
not meet the standard our previous
standard for pfoa and pfos were 12 and
15 respectively those are the current
state standards that we enforce but once
we adopt this four par petran standard
there will be at least 150 to 200 Public
additional Public Water Systems in the
state that don't meet the standard and
we'll have to put on treatment or find
some other solution to make sure that
they're supplying compliant water and
safe safe clean drinking water and uh
the the word for public or for private
drinking water wells we we can only
estimate that but we we know a fair lot
bit about it because we've sampled over
12,000 private drinking water wells over
the last 10 years for pasas and um we
based on the data we have and making
some reasonable projections we
anticipate that there will be
potentially tens of thousands of private
drinking water wells that will be over
that four part petran standard so it's a
formidable problem you know the word
unprecedented is overused but I don't
think it's uh hyperbole in this case
this is an unprecedented impact of
drinking water in the state that we've
been dealing with over the last 10
years if I could follow up if I heard
you correctly earlier you said those
fortunate enough to be near a
public uh Source could Poe T could
poet um but now what you're saying is
that's not necessarily the solution well
no so um and I want to draw a
distinction this this section seven of
this bill provides a very specific right
of action so if you are a person who um
uh whose well has been impacted by a
release from a past facility and you're
over the standard and you have not been
offered a solution from that party um
then this gives you a right of action to
to try to to get that from that party
the broader problem of Pas contamination
in the state is going to be addressed
through a variety of means the state has
already put tremendous resources to we
we we we Implement a rebate program
right now where people who have
contamination in their well over
standards that have not been offered
solution can put a point of entry
treatment system on and they're eligible
for um up to a $5,000 rebate to offset
the costs of that um and we also provide
up to 10,000 for connection to a water
system um so the the the solution to
these you know this new recognition that
we have a tremendous number of increased
number of of of Wells that are
potentially going to be above this new
below this above this new standard
that's that there's going to be a
manifold solution for that it's going to
involve responsible parties it's going
to involve um New Hampshire state
government and the federal government
the federal government is is trying to
um or is uh appropriating resources to
address that they're probably not
sufficient to address the whole problem
but they are putting some money towards
it that that they're passing on to the
states other questions for this witness
yes representative trip thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
uh this new standard that uh is being
established is that going to be through
uh legislative or
regulations so the the the federal
government has implemented um and they
my understanding is it'll be published
in the Federal Register this month and
will likely be then officially effective
in in June
um that will be a federal drinking water
MCL um State programs across the country
um typically and and and state law
essentially um uh anticipates that the
state will adopt any federal MCL that's
adopted will generally be adopted by the
state it typically would be done by by
administrative rule although it could be
done by by law in the case of our
current P standards the the current P
drinking water standards in New
Hampshire were actually established by
the legislature back in 2019 as OPP and
then we we followed up with implementing
rulemaking but the actual setting those
standards was done by law so it could
happen either
way follow up please sure yes so
modification of Standards could be done
by the uh
Dees yes we are uh we are authorized by
the legislature under our state Safe
Drinking Water Act and our groundwater
protection act to establish both
drinking water standard and um
groundwater standards thank you other
questions so I guess I have just a
couple of questions I want to make sure
I'm understand is am I understanding
from your testimony that at the present
time there is not a private right of
action for contamination of a well by P
um I and again I I am not an attorney so
I'm going to I'm going to I'm going to
tell you my understanding of it my
understanding is that that any party
could you know file a right of action
against or file a a suit against a
responsible party for who who they
believe is contaminated their well this
just provides an explicit right of
action the the the I think what this is
trying to do is provide firmer legal
legal legal U footing for for a person
who's trying to do that and it gives
them a specific goal that basically that
this this bill would say you can file
this action and under the law the party
would be responsible to provide you with
safe clean water in a very specific
way okay and can I just a couple of
other questions is that the
10,000 uh parts per trillion is that a
standard that was was one set by the
legislature as you or that was one set
by no no and actually the the the
original version of this bill that was
as it was introduced in the Senate set
it at a much lower standard at 100 parts
per trillion and to be very candid that
the business community and others were
very concerned about that they felt that
that was going to cast too wide a net
with respect to Pas contamination and so
um the senator was uh was willing to
amend the bill to raise that number to
10,000 that 10,000 based on the data we
have right now and it could change in
the future but the data we have right
now really probably applies to about
four facilities we we know that there
are about four facilities in the state
that fit the definition of a
manufacturer and that they have released
past contamination and they have
contaminated groundwater at a
concentration greater than 10,000 parts
per trillion I think that the you know
at some level the Genesis of this bill
is in part you know our biggest site the
one associated with the St gobain
facility in
miramac has to be said has contaminated
thousands of drinking water wells and
the state negotiated consent agreement
with with st gobain back in
2018 I believe it was based on the
information we had about the occurrence
of the contaminant and the standard at
the time which was 70 parts per trillion
and basically that uh um consent
agreement under state law it gave the
state authority to or or it's
essentially it was agreed by the company
that within a certain boundary that was
drawn which included about it was huge
it was 5 T 64 square miles within that
boundary St gobain agreed to provide uh
ground uh alternate water for any
parties whose Wells they had
contaminated in that in that within that
area
um outside of it under the terms of the
agreement they would only be responsible
under
State Dees authority to provide
alternate water if they contaminated
well Above That 70 par petran standard
and um that based on what we knew at the
time seemed like a reasonable approach
what we unfortunately learned later is
that in fact the their contamination
while we had a pretty good idea how how
far it spread we had no idea that the
standard would then be with based on new
toxicological data would be reduced
significantly down to 12 parts per
trillion and when you look at that same
map at 12 parts per trillion it was
clear to us that there were facilities
outside that consent decree boundary
that were contaminated above the 12 part
per trillion but then under the agency
would not have the authority under the
consent agreement to require the company
to provide alternate water to those
folks so there are several hundred if
not more than a thousand parties whose
Wells very likely were contaminated by
the company that um uh are not we're not
in a position to compel the company to
provide alternate water so what this
bill would do it's my understanding of
the Senator's desires was to help those
constituents of hers who who are very
likely impacted by the company's
contamination um but who are not they're
not being required to be provided with
alternate water because the state is
constrained by the terms of the consent
agreement so this gives them a firmer
legal footing to act on their
own and that would be true for other
facilities as well who meet the
definition so I I guess the thing I'm
not I'm not clear I understand if the if
it sounds like you're saying that the
standard for when something is could be
dangerous to health so to speak is way
below 10,000 parts per trillion it's I
think you mentioned 70 so if that's true
why are we why are we limiting I mean it
sounds like there's we're we're we're
excluding from liability a
huge uh number of of uh polluters right
I I think it's important to understand
that the the 10,000 part per trillion is
an attempt to um limit this or or
address this private right of action to
the most significant sites in and
clearly that's one of the most
significant sites the other sites are
also large that that are the four sites
um needs to be said that the parties who
have contamination don't have to be
contaminated at 10,000 parts per
trillion this is the the 10,000 standard
is just to say if anywhere on the site
and basically these facilities have not
contaminated drinking water wells at
10,000 parts per trilon they've
contaminated groundwater near their near
their facility at that level so that
establishes them as is a very
significant major releaser of pasas once
you get through that hurdle you're
you're you're encompassed by this
legislation and then anybody whose well
you have impacted over the standard um
which is 12 right now and will likely be
four is is is eligible to to use the the
provisions of this law to get a some
kind of a remedy um and it also should
be said that this is not to say that a
party who has contaminated groundwater
at a lesser concentration than that
might not still have some liability
under the law this is just trying to
make explicit that if you are in this
larger category of a significant
releaser who's who's contaminated
groundwater at this very high level then
you you you there is an explicit right
of action for parties who have been
harmed by by your release even and if
I'm understanding even in other words if
you if you are a significant releaser MH
then you are subject to this and
somebody who may have been harmed even
by a significantly lower amount would
have the right to bring the action
that's exactly right so the with our
current law and if this bill were to
pass if you are a residential property
owner in Bedford who owns a home whose
well has been impacted by the releases
from the company um at 13 parts per
trillion your one part per trillion over
the 12 part per Tron standard this would
the provisions of this bill would apply
to you and you could you would have this
private right of action that's that's
that's how we understand it okay all
right just one final question I I see
and there was some mention um I think
during your testimony or maybe it was
the Senator's testimony about any person
who operates so I guess my question is
does this in other words if I'm if I'm
uh in some kind of supervisory position
let's say with st Caines am I personally
liable now for this or I don't think
that's what this this is a person you
know in terms of the legal definition as
certainly I don't have to tell you know
the definition of person has different
meanings in different um in in in
different uh um in different setting
different statutory Frameworks this I
believe this was just to make clear that
um uh you know it could
be I mean the definition for a past
facility is already relatively narrow
here it includes basically a facility
that's used these compounds in for
manufacturing so basically that's
typically going to be a company or of of
some structure and it just the the RSA
147b I believe is generally used um
person to mean this particular thing but
I don't think this is I I'm not aware
that anything in this imposes personal
individual liability on an employee of a
well I I I mean I you know the the
language says any person who owns and
owns I can understand you know that
presumably does not cover the employee
but any person who operates and so if
I'm the manager of St Goin uh am I
personally liable that's not been my
understanding that the the the the the
owner operator concept is the
longstanding language in this statute
and it's companion statute 147a and I
think the purpose of it is really to say
you might operate a manufacturing
facility on leased property so if you
just say owner and you're on a lease
property then you could say well I'm not
an owner I just operate here so I think
really operators intended to be the
company that operates the facility even
if it's on leased property all right
other questions for this witness being
none thank you very much sir thank you
uh is there anyone else who uh wishes to
413 seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing on uh Senate Bill
413 thank you very much uh and it's well
my I think that clock is a little bit
fast I think we got two
minutes thank you for chair no no
oh yeah that would be great thank you
the next bill that's for the next bill
yeah uh what she's she's yeah I don't
know where Kaitlyn she's in Disney I
think she's in Disney she's in Disney
she's watching remotely iming these and
she's oh all right okay okay you guys
got everything covered that's
yeah I saw Tim yeah he he said he had to
so I know that
I'm so I'm waiting for them to tell
on oh they they're on they're on the
third Bill we're the fifth so I you know
they're going to call Bob and and me we
right all right well it's now 10:30 uh
so I'm going to open the hearing on
Senate Bill 422 and I recognize the
Carson good morning Mr chairman and good
morning members of the House judiciary
committee for the record my name is
Sharon Carson and I have the pleasure of
representing Senate District 14
comprising the towns of londondary
Hudson and Auburn and I have for your
consideration this morning Senate Bill
422 which is changing several references
and modifying language in parentage and
birth records um this bill has been um
was amended in the Senate based upon the
number of of responses that we had
gotten because um in the original
language the uh terms mother and father
had been removed um so I worked with the
attorneys both our Senate attorney and
the attorneys that asked me to bring
this forward to put birth mother and
birth father back
in so what does this bill actually do
well this bill updates New Hampshire law
that a that so that the acknowledgement
of parentage or what is known as
aops um also called voluntary
acknowledgement of parentage or vaps a
lot of acronyms here can be signed for
children born through assisted
reproduction and gam donation this means
more children can have their parentage
parentage established at close to birth
and through a voluntary process rather
than requiring their parents to go to
court to file leg legit
litigation this will also increase
efficiencies in the
court Mr chair I was astonished and I
learned this a few years ago that um
couples who had used assistant
reproduction actually had to go and
adopt their own
children um it was astounding that they
had to hire an attorney they had to go
through this legal process to have legal
rights for their own children and this
bill will help that
process um it's important that for these
children and their families to have
equal access to the security of legal
parentage and since vaps are equivalent
to court decrees this means New
Hampshire children will be protected
wherever they travel Senate Bill 422 has
been developed in cons in consultation
with the New Hampshire vital records and
New Hampshire child support um I had
also heard of children that were born
outside of marriage um where the other
party the birth father did not sign the
birth certificate and it came time to go
through um you know the couple separated
someone wants child support they have to
establish parentage first so if they
sign this form they're good to go and
and they're now legally responsible um
for those children what does it not do
this bill does not change who can be a
parent in New Hampshire it simply lets
current parents protect their children
through these
vaps why is this important it's a key
public policy goal to secure the
parentage of children efficiently and
soon after birth parentage is a source
of All rights and responsibilities for
children like health insurance financial
support and medical decision-making by
allowing children born through assisted
reproduction equal access to parentage
through a VAP form New Hampshire ensures
these children are protected more
quickly and without the expense and
delay of filing litigation in court why
is it important for efficiency right now
children born through assisted
reproduction can only be secured through
the court or the litigation process
whereas other children s can be secured
through an aop with this bill there
should be fewer cases going to court
because parents of children born through
assisted reproduction can use the aop
form like all other parents
do um who supports this bill this is a
common sense bill that enjoys the
support of the New Hampshire Hospital
Association local practitioners and The
Academy of adoption and assisted
reproduction attorneys as well as
involvement from Key stakeholders like
vital records and child support this
bill is consistent with Federal
requirements as well as best practices
moving through other States since the
mid 1990s federal law has required each
state have a simple civil process to
establish parentage this is again the
voluntary acknowled acknowledgement of
parentage process the goal of this
Federal program is to ensure that
parents are secured to their children
for the purpose of support and health
insurance so parents are supporting
their children rather than the
government each state has a VAP form and
a majority of children born to unmarried
mothers and fathers have their parentage
form uh parentage secured through the
VAP form states have moved as
recommended by the UPA of
2017 to expand access to VAP so that
more children can be secured through
this program 12 states have moved to
expand access to this process to more
children um Mr chairman
in in ackowledgement of time um I'm not
going to read the 12 States but um more
states have are doing this and have
actually filed um legislation this year
for this same process so at this point
Mr chairman I will conclude my testimony
if I will try to answer any questions
but uh the attorneys are here as well as
the department and they can speak to
that but I will try to answer some
questions great thank you thank you very
much Senator and you know what I'm uh
representative Smith and I have to go uh
over to testify before your chamber uh
this afternoon no right now oh so um so
we're going to leave I'm going to turn
the hearing over to uh Vice chair
Wallace and we will be back as soon as
we can um I completely
understand yes rep representative
lonza um thank you for taking my
question I just have a question about uh
what happens when the father um does not
want to uh sign there are times that um
I'm a labor and delivery nurse so there
are times that um the fathers do not
sign um or the um couple has broken up
before they even um was they say come to
um so um thank you very much for the
question this is where I believe you're
probably going to have to go through the
courts um it's unfortunate uh when that
happens so you're going to have to
establish genetically the father's
responsibility and then you're going to
have to go to court um where they will
be held legally responsible but this is
for people to do voluntarily and most
voluntarily representative trip thank
you Mr Vice chair thanks for taking my
question it uh I almost felt like it was
in a Schoolboard meeting when you were
giving your testimony because uh you
seem to like
acronyms representative they're not my
acronyms well hopefully you know what
they are uh what you use aops and
vaps could you yes the aops is called it
is the acknowledgement of
parentage and the
parentage that clears a lot of things up
thank you you're
welcome any further questions for
Senator
Carson seeing none thank you thank you
very much Mr chairman uh we now call
Christine
Hansen thank you representative Wallace
um it's hanisco Christine hanisco my
apologies no problem it's that's a tough
one um thank you members of the
committee I submitted my testimony
online but I also brought a copy for you
day um I um am an attorney I'm a
resident of conquer and uh I had my own
children one of whom is with me today
since it's school vacation um through
assisted reproduction so I'm very
intimately familiar with this process um
we did have to use a donor and I gave
birth to the twins almost 11 years ago
and their father who I'm not married to
was able to sign what's known as a
voluntary acknowledgement of paternity
so what this bill does is it takes away
the gender issues because what happens
is if a female couple who's unmarried
presents in the hospital at delivery
even if they used Anonymous donor sperm
at this point in time only the birth
parent can go on the birth certificate
and that then triggers the process for
the other partner to have to go to court
and establish their parentage so even
though they selected the donor together
they paid for the sperm together they
did all they're living together they're
maintaining a household they're
responsible they may even be on the
non-birth parents Insurance the child
they can't legally establish their um
parentage without that court process and
this um this body actually helped us fix
that process a couple years back so this
really is I think I've lost a little bit
of but I think we're on our third bill
that has taken a lot of our different
statutes because they are scattered
throughout the code and updated them to
be consistent with each other to be
consistent with federal law and to make
sure that all families are protected and
that we have now covered all of these
various ways that they can be covered so
uh representative lansa to answer your
question when a person doesn't want to
sign that could be the father
genetically but it may also be a couple
who in the course of creating their uh
procuring their donor sperm and having
that pregnancy may have split up that
happens too I had an attorney consult
with me just this month on that type of
an issue and now what happens so it
could be either a male or female person
and that's the problem right currently
our hospitals our nurses are faced with
this awkwardness of asking these
questions instead of just registering
the birth the way the couple intended um
at the Judiciary um in the Senate there
was very powerful testimony read by an
attorney who had assisted a couple faced
with that situation where the paperwork
had all been filled out and then the
registar said oh wait you're married
right and they said no we're not married
and she ripped up the paperwork so very
tra IC to them to be having just given
birth and to have someone rip up the
paperwork that supported both of their
names being on the birth
certificate um we had made attempts over
the last several years to see if we
could fix this problem through our um
administrative offices but this code
these Provisions fall in both DHHS and
vital records and so the complexity
there and the number of sections that
were impacted ultimately it was decid
the best way to do it is by bringing
this bill um and we really thank um
Senator Carson and all of the
co-sponsors for their support I'm happy
to answer questions um but I do think
it's a just really basic Common Sense
bill that's long
overdue representative trip Mr chair
thank you for taking my question you use
the uh phras establishing their
parentage could you explain what that
means sure so under um current law we
have two ways of that happening the
first is what's known as a marital
presumption so when a person gives birth
their spouse is automatically presumed
to be the parent even if they are not
genetically the parent and automatically
both people will be placed on the birth
certificate it's what's known as a
rebuttable presumption so they could
somebody could challenge that with a
court action to remove the non- genetic
person from the birth certificate
through litigation so that's the first
way that parentage can be established is
that marital presumption the person that
gives birth is automatically considered
the parent unless it was through just
stational care uh sergy which is a whole
separate process I don't want to confuse
us but we addressed the problems there
too last year um so if it's the
automatically the birth parent goes on
the certificate and their
spouse when they're not married the only
way for the non-birth parent to do that
is through a voluntary acknowledgement
form currently it is only for paternity
only a male can sign it and so it's
leaving a group of people and their
children
unprotected does that further follow up
followup please
uh I I assume that the term
parentage uh involves certain rights and
responsibilities
correct yes and they are they are
financial support um they are care what
we we we as attorneys talk about care
custody and control you have the right
to parenting time even if if you live in
separate houses you have the right to um
make medical decisions you have the
right to make educational decisions and
you have a financial responsibility to
support the
child thank you you're so
welcome representative
Lonzo thank you for taking my question I
just have a quick question about um so
if you have two male um uh couple and
they had um had a um person that was I
say um they used as um the do I guess
the um they would use an egg donor andal
carrier right and so um what is the
process that they have have to go um
through afterwards um because one of
them will be the I guess considered
father and um do they then have to go to
court after that so that is that is the
um
169 sorry
168b um that chapter addresses just
stational carriers and how that works
and so anybody who's using a surrogate
for to carry the birth would go through
a parentage petition in the probate
division of our circuit court that
actually happens before birth so this
bill does not apply to couples who use a
gestational carrier because their
parentage is going to be established
before the carrier gives birth so that's
already been happening we've been um and
as I said we updated that chapter last
year um and so they are going to both
both parents regardless of gender are
going to be named right from birth
because we're going to have a court
order before the baby's even delivered
um there it does the statute does allow
for it to happen after the fact um and
that does sometimes need to happen
um and then also sometimes babies are
born early and the courts just haven't
gotten to issuing the order yet so we do
have the ability to do it after birth
but I would I don't have the stats on it
but I would Hazard that almost all are
birth follow up please
and am I correct in saying that um many
other states do not allow that to occur
but this um in our state we do allow
that allow which to have a um was let
you say the Don the donor and they have
a two like male couple and surrogacy
yeah um actually that's not accurate um
we with respect to uh
surrogacy um there's only at this point
in time I think two or three states left
where it is um not allowed and it can
even be a criminal act Michigan just
overturned in the past month their
statute that was um made it criminal uh
New York did a few years ago New Jersey
a few years before that so we're
actually at a point in time now where
almost all 50 states are allowing sorcy
the process may look a little different
from state to state of how that
parentage is established but that is
that does exist and with vaps as Senator
Carson um testified to we have um we're
now at 12 Michigan being the most recent
and that literally has been since we
were over in um the Senate on this bill
um so they're the most recent we are the
only New England State at this time that
does not have this uh gender neutral
approach and I and just another point of
clarification also um our version also
will allow married couples to do this so
it's not uh just
Oregan I know
um I guess the uh we're still using the
word mother in there which will probably
uh make it easier to get this bill
passed through the house um which is so
is there I guess there isn't actually a
definition of of mother I know there's
controversy over like using a different
term since sometimes someone who
identifies as nonbinary or even male
whether in transition can get pregnant
and even give birth and uh which which I
think is fine but to that I'm sorry I'm
sorry to overp speak you um that was why
the amendment was brought in the Senate
was to make sure we you our goal was to
keep it as gender neutral as possible
that was that were there was push back
as Senator Carson uh testified to and so
that is why the
amendment all right
thanks any other questions seeing none
thank you thank
Bradley thanks Mr chairman members of
the committee for the record my name is
Ben Bradley I'm the vice president of
state government relations for the New
Hampshire Hospital Association as uh
Senator Carson pointed out we are in
strong support of this bill and
appreciate her sponsorship of an
important issue
um we support updating the language in
the birth worksheet and birth records to
make the forms more inclusive by using
terms such as birth parent and non-birth
parent updating the language in these
documents will help ensure all patients
and their families are able to complete
the forms without confusion further the
proposed changes are inclusive and will
help healthc Care Professionals provide
compassionate and inclusive care we
support efforts to ensure that all
patients and their families feel
comfortable when seeking Medical Care
and that includes ensuring they have the
ability to choose how to be addressed
and recorded when giving birth thanks
for the opportunity to testify I'm happy
questions any questions for this witness
seeing none thank you thanks and
thank you Mr vice president or vice
chair excuse me um and members of the
committee thank you for giving me the
opportunity to speak on Senate Bill
422 my name is Lisa decowski and I am
the bureau chief with the Bureau of
Child Support Services here representing
uh the New Hampshire Department of
Health and Human Services our Bureau of
Child Support Services of course
administers the child support program
that was established uh through the
title uh Roman numeral 4D uh part of the
Social Security Act of
1975 um as it was already mentioned uh
one of the primary
responsibilities of the child support
program uh is to uh
establish uh paternity currently or
legal fatherhood and or
parentage um we are here today uh to
provide information uh to the committee
uh just in relation to some some of the
potential implementation of the changes
uh as proposed in the bill uh because of
our Administration over the existing uh
Affidavit of paternity form and
subsequent procedures um so as a you
know we are certainly the department is
supportive of the intent uh and the
goals um and these uh language changes
do align with what we know our federal
partners of our office of child Support
Services is also recommending for
proposed rule
changes uh uh relative to shifting
language from paternity to parentage in
those regulations to which our program
is required uh to adhere to um it
already has been stated that uh
parentage establishment is necessary
first step in our child support
processes um when children are born out
of marriage um and the bill uh doesn't
conflict uh as it is currently written
with our ability to operate our continue
to operate our state child program nor
does it limit our ability to continue to
pursue our core functions um and we have
a great working relationship and
partnership with our Vital Records our
state Vital Records Division
collaboration with them and the other
stakeholders so we feel uh that any of
the changes that are made should this
bill be enacted uh we should be able to
implement and absorb those uh changes
within our existing resources we
certainly do appreciate the Bill's
effective date of uh July 1 2025 that
will allow us the proper time to make
any of the necessary changes that may be
needed to our forms and training um and
uh should there be any questions of the
committee the Bureau of Child Support
Services we'd be happy to try and answer
them to the best of our ability
otherwise I just thank you for the
opportunity to speak
speak thank you any
questions seeing none we thank you for
your
testimony is there anybody else who
would wish to speak regarding Senate
Bill
422 seeing none we'll close our hearing
and uh we'll reconvene at 11 o'clock
thank
you
e
okay it's 11 o'clock little after
Senator Carson
yours good morning Mr chairman um and
again for the record my name is Sharon
Carson and I have the pleasure of
representing Senate District 14
comprising the towns of London da Hudson
and Auburn and I have for your
consideration this morning Senate Bill
462 which seeks to raise the cap on
Damages for wrongful death loss of
Consortium claims um Mr chairman this
bill started out as eliminating the Caps
um but during the Senate public hearing
we got a tremendous amount of push back
from the insurance industry they really
wanted to keep the caps in place so in
an effort to compromise we did that and
what we ended up doing was raising the
amount um from 300,000 to 5 uh excuse me
from
150,000 to
500,000 I think it's important to
realize that the caps for this has they
have not changed in 30 years um it has
been it has been artificially low so um
it doesn't change anything in the
current statute but the amount of
Damages that can be recovered by a
spouse or minor child for the loss of
the enjoyment of their loved ones life
if they were killed by the negligence of
another um these claims again are very
limited in scope and can be very very
difficult to prove in New Hampshire we
have a long tradition in the belief and
Trust in the right to trial by a jury of
one of our peers who would be
determining exactly what the damages
would be um there's a couple of points
that I I would like to make our level of
compensation is so low that the federal
government when determining cases in New
Hampshire will not use our number in
fact they use the state of which is a
million
do um I the other thing I would like to
point out there's a couple points um say
you decide you're going to go over to
Maine um we got great Seafood in New
Hampshire but some people like to go to
Maine to have a seafood dinner
especially if you're close um you live
along the border um and if you should
lose your spouse say in an automobile
accident due to the negligence of
another person their life is worth a
million dollars but if you were to have
that same accident in New Hampshire it's
only worth
150 so we're trying to raise this um one
of the things that we heard was it's
going to raise insurance rates and I
think this is something that we are all
acutely aware of and I've handed a copy
of a recent article on dated April
19th um from the union leader that talks
about insurance premiums are on the rise
and and here's why and it's because of
weather related industry accidents and
things that are happening people are
getting a lot of property damage so um
you're going to hear the insurance
industry talk about oh my God the
insurance rates are going to rise well
guess what folks they're go they're
going to rise anyway these are not
claims that are come forward very often
so I think it's time that we raise these
rates um to reflect today's prices um
and really quite
frankly $500,000 can that compensate you
for the loss of your
spouse um or your children's mother or
their your children's father think about
what it costs to raise a child today and
if you lose one of the individuals in
your family who contributes financially
think about this the mother who's now a
single mom and she's now has to raise
those children yes there might be other
sources that you can tap into but you've
got to now go back to work you have to
pay for daycare and I think we've had
really great discussions about the cost
of daycare if you can find it here in
New Hampshire the cost of educating and
raising a child so every little bit
helps and all we're trying to do is to
help those who through no fault of their
own they've lost they're a loved one and
now they're left alone so um at this
point I will conclude my testimony Mr
chairman um there are uh folks there are
a lot of folks here that will probably
want to discuss this with you um who
have uh other pertinent points that
they'd like to make so at this point I
will conclude my testimony thank you rep
uh Mr chairman thank you Senator Carson
oh Mr chairman I do have the pink card I
will pass it to representative thank you
and seeing no questions for Senator
Carson we'll call the next witness uh
Holly
Haynes thank you chairman Wallace and
thank you members of the committee for
allowing me to testify today I am here
on behalf of the New Hampshire
Association for justice as well as all
of my clients my name is Holly Haynes I
am an attorney in Manchester New
Hampshire and I practice medical
malpractice and personal injury law I've
represented numerous Estates of
claimants who have been killed by
negligence as well as who have been
permanently harmed by negligence and I
can tell you unequivocally that the loss
of a spouse or a loved one the loss of a
familial relation relationship impacts
New Hampshire citizens exactly the same
way whether their loved one is killed by
negligent conduct or permanently harmed
by negligent
conduct what's not the same is how the
law treats those two losses and this
disparity later in my testimony I'm
going to give you an example of the
disperate impact that this law has on
families who are per who lose a loved
one to death versus someone who is
catastrophically injured but before I do
I know that there are a lot of concerns
that this is a significant expansion of
the law a significant change in the law
and I want to tell you that nothing
could be further from the case this bill
is extremely narrow in scope it doesn't
create any new causes of action it is
not going to increase the number of
lawsuits that businesses
face it's not going to create any new
classes of plaintiffs or any new classes
of claims that people can bring
it doesn't require any additional proof
at trial that's going to increase
litigation costs and it doesn't increase
or create any new elements of claims all
that it does is raise the arbitrary cap
that exists on Damages for claims for
loss of familiar
relationship I'm sure that you are going
to hear during the course of this
hearing from uh representatives of the
insurance industry who are going to
express concerns about the increased
insurance premiums and how it's going to
drive business out of New Hampshire
these concerns are not well founded
though because if loss of Consortium
claims are considered at all in
establishing their premiums which I
submit they probably are not um
businesses and insurers already have to
consider those because law of Consortium
claims are brought with any injury
action this is the only one that has a
cap on it loss of Consortium claims are
derivative of the underlying negligence
claim insurers are already uring
themselves against loss they're
Insurance insuring them themselves
against claims this Consortium claim is
only part of that underlying claim it's
not a separate claim it is not going to
change any of their reserves or their
premiums at its Essence this bill is
just going to make the wrongful death
statute comport with existing negligence
claims and right now it's the only
existing cap on tort damages other than
for volunteers at nonprofit
organizations or for the limited caps
for sovereign immunity proc claims
against the state or counties or
municipalities another concern you're
going to hear is that eliminating this
cap will likely result in more claims
being filed or create the potential for
Runaway Jury verdicts and I'm going to
explain to you why that's not the case
by telling you how these claims actually
work in New Hampshire and what's
happening in New Hampshire as well as
what's happening in the other New
England states regarding Consortium
claim claims and the practical
application and disperate impact this
has no one who testifies today is going
to tell you that there are frivolous
lawsuits in New Hampshire no one's going
to tell you that the costs of lawsuits
have driven up insurance premiums or
costs in New Hampshire and the reasons
for this are three-fold New Hampshire is
a very very small state lawyers value
their reputations we pride ourselves on
our reputations in the community with
the courts and with our opposing
councils we take our job very seriously
and we don't bring claims that don't
have Merit because that's not going to
benefit
anyone the New Hampshire Civil Justice
System and jury system guaranteed by our
constitution also works jurors in New
Hampshire take their civic duty very
seriously they do not they listen to the
evidence in each case they follow the
law they don't award runaway
verdicts I'm sure all of you know you've
never seen any headlines in New
Hampshire about Runaway verdicts that
you see in other states because they
just don't happen and if there is one
the judge has the power to reduce that
Verdict by reditor it's completely
within the discretion of the court and
it doesn't need to be created or limited
by the
legislature finally there are really
strong financial disincentives to
Bringing fris claims it costs a lot of
money to bring a medical malpractice or
wrongful death lawsuit often hundreds of
thousands of dollars are spent just on
Expert Witnesses alone to bring these
claims and if a meritorious case loses
at trial those costs are borne by the
lawyers they aren't going to bring that
claim PR frivolously because they're
never going to recoup those
costs the contingency Fe method for
payment for attorneys also prevents
privis claims from being
filed if an attorney's not successful in
getting a verdict or settlement they
aren't going to get paid so they aren't
going to bring a frivolous claim that
they don't think is going to be
successful uccessful we take a lot of
time and we spend a lot of money in
screening all claims that we bring at
our office
and before we decide to bring a claim we
probably take one out of a 100 cases
that come through our doors or who
contact our office they are few and far
between
and wrongful death claims are even
fewer this is how claims work in a
traditional case if a medical
malpractice case comes to our office for
a someone's wrongful death we meet with
the estate representative or family
member to find out exactly what happened
after that meeting we spend thousands of
dollars getting all of the victim's
medical records having them reviewed by
medical experts in the appropriate
Specialties to determine whether or not
negligence if our expert doesn't give us
a positive opinion we decline the case
we may have spent thousands of dollars
but we're going to decline the case we
aren't going to pursue that case
frivolously expert Witnesses cost
sometimes up to $1,000 an hour just to
review a case they are making money off
of these cases it's
not the plaintiffs who are bringing
them we only file suit if a medical
expert gives us support that medical
negligence happened and that the
death and it's really important to note
that there can be no Consortium claim
unless there is an underlying
malpractice claim or an underlying
wrongful death
claim also the damages for wrongful
death claims are limited by Statute it's
a creature of Statute it was created by
Statute it didn't exist at the common
law all the plaintiffs are allowed to
recover in wrongful death claims are
their conscious pain and suffering
before death their medical bills and
funeral expenses that they
incur the duration of life and years of
life that they've lost their life
expectancy the Lost earnings and their
earning capacity and then the lck loss
of comfort companionship and society
that is the Consortium claim that is
suffered by the spouse or the
children in many cases a victim is
killed instantaneously in a car accident
or during a medical procedure so there's
no conscious pain or suffering that can
be
claimed in cases where a decedent is
unemployed if they're a homemaker if
they're retired if they're disabled
probably the people who have the
greatest Financial need there are going
to be no economic losses that can be
claimed because they don't have lost
wages that can be claimed they don't
have those financial um expenses to
claim the only damages in those cases
that can be claimed are the loss of the
familiar relationship and the loss of
the life and I submit to
you no one's spouse I don't think anyone
would place a value of $150,000 on their
spouse's life or $50,000 on their
child's life if a child loses a parent I
think anyone would give any amount of
money to get that person back and not to
trial thankfully in New Hampshire
wrongful death cases are very few and
far
between they only happen when another
New Hampshire citizen or business kills
another New Hampshire citizen through
their negligent conduct the only way to
reduce and eliminate wrongful death
claims
is to reduce and eliminate negligent
conduct that's how we get rid of them
and that's how we prevent them and
unfortunately the only way to do that is
to make people pay compensation when
they act
negligently wrongful death claims with
Consortium claims are even fewer and far
between because it means that the person
who was killed left behind a spouse or a
minor child and wrongful death claims
that are going to get compensation under
the statute
are the ones where where the family
members needed the most because they
didn't have economic losses that can be
recovered for the loss of their loved
one by way of example um if a person or
business causes a drunk driving crash
and the driver has a policy limit of a
million dollars if the person killed was
a young physician who's making hundreds
of thousands of dollars a year who has a
young spouse young
children the estate of that position is
going to get the entire $1 million
policy limit without ever reaching the
Consortium claim because the Physicians
lost wages lost earnings and economic
losses to the estate are going to take
the entire policy limit in that case the
Consortium claim doesn't even come into
play because it doesn't trigger
additional policy limits our Supreme
Court decided that in 2006 it's not
going to change anything in that claim
at all in contrast so if the drunk
driving accident happens and the deedon
is a home uh Homemaker who homeschools
her
children there are no lost wages there
are no lost earnings and there are no
economic losses that family is going to
be limited to the loss of the life and
the $150,000 for the loss of the spouse
and $50,000 for the loss of the parent
there shouldn't be such a disparity just
because someone is making a lot of money
or has a higher profession or higher
wage New Hampshire's citizens lives are
same if
in all catastrophic cases in each case
where the New Hampshire Supreme Court
has struck down damage caps as being
unconstitutional um in fact our Supreme
Court has done that in every case that
they've addressed damage caps and it's
seminal case of Parson versus Moore
which I um outlined in my written
testimony the Supreme Court explained
why caps on Damages are unconstitutional
and made clear quote recovery of only a
limited portion of damages cannot be the
equivalent to recovery of such damages
in full Society cannot Escape its
responsibility to its
citizens to provide Justice simply by
eliminating the rights of its citizens
New Hampshire law has not kept up with
this
principle this is what's happening in
other states we're the only New England
state with a cap on Damages for wrongful
death of less than a million dollar
Vermont Massachusetts Connecticut and
Rhode Island have no
caps um main is the only other state in
New England that has a cap on Damages
and its current cap is a million dollar
New York prohibits damages caps and
wrongful death cases in its
Constitution our federal court in 2011
in a choice of law analysis uh
recognized that New Hampshire had not
kept up with its fellow New England
states and had not kept up with the rest
of the country in that case um now
deceased judge de clerico observed that
New Hampshire lies in quote the
Backwater of the modern stream
for damages and wrongful death cases and
when he was given the choice to apply
Maine or New Hampshire law he chose to
apply Main's law because it would better
serve the end of ends of justice for our
New Hampshire citizen who was a plup in
that
case I want to tell you about a client
of mine to give you the more practical
application of this damages cap in
action um I've represented a 41-year-old
Navy veteran uh Carol
Martin she was married for 20 years to
her husband Gary
Martin she had four children who she
homeschooled they all had special needs
um one of them had severe
autism the mother suffered a back injury
and she went to our VA Medical Center
she had a back injury in the Navy and
she exacerbated it when she fell at home
despite being opiate naive which means
she didn't take opiate medications
regularly um the doctors threw p
medication at her they threw a fenel
patch which they replaced in 2 days with
the fenel patch triple the dose they
discharged her with prescriptions for
morphine and oxycoton along with 10
Fentanyl patches and they sent her home
and this wife and mother died in her bed
she was found by two of her children of
an opiate overdose because of
overprescribing by PHS the children at
the time she died were 9 11 15 and 17
the 17-year-old was just 10 days shy of
his 18th birthday had he been 18 he
wouldn't have had a claim at all that
shouldn't
happen there was no wage claim to be
made because she was a homemaker and she
homeschooled her kids in fact in that
case which was a federal twer claim in
federal court the defense Economist
actually testified that the estate
suffered a negative net economic loss
meaning they benefited positively from
the death of this woman because she
would have consumed more over her
lifetime than she contributed
economically that can't be the way we
value wrongful death cases her husband
her children all suffered
catastrophically her children suffered
to this day they had to transition to
public school they had special needs and
autism the IEPs they needed one couldn't
finish school others are still suffering
to this day and their claims were
limited to $50,000 because of the
statute those children deserved a lot
more more her husband was limited to
$150,000 the oldest son would have
gotten nothing if it had been 10 days
later in contrast I represented another
family involving a 50-year-old wife and
mother who was rendered functionally a
newborn after medical procedures were
mismanaged um to treat an unruptured
inter cranial aneurysm and it resulted
in multiple frontal L Strokes she was
left partially paralyzed she lost her
memory she lost her recognition of her
husband and her children she didn't
recognize any family members she was
placed in a home for brain injured
patients in the North Country her
husband of more than 20 years was left
without his wife her five children two
who were adopted were left without a
mother she too wasn't working she helped
out in the family business just keeping
the books and she homeschooled her
children so she too didn't have a wage
loss claim in that case though the
Probate Judge awarded more than half of
the malpractice settlement to the
husband and the family for the loss of
the familial relationship of their
mother and wife and had his wife died as
opposed to being
rendered permanently disabled he would
have been limited to
$150,000 their losses were very much the
same they both completely lost their
spouses and parents but the outcomes of
what they were able to recover was
dressed ically different and I submit to
you that isn't the way that the law
should
work the damages cap that we have right
now is arbitrary it's irrational and it
has not changed in 30 years it is so low
um I do know that several people have
submitted valid concerns I saw a letter
from the nurse practitioner administ uh
Association I know that the hospital
Association other medical associations
have many valid concerns um that are
well founded about cost of malpractice
premiums and about obstetrical providers
being driven out of the state or
neurologic providers or nurse
practitioners being driven out of
business I submit to you that those have
nothing to do with the statute though
the statute does not impact those claims
at all malpractice
claims involving birth injuries or
neurologic
injuries the reason that the awards are
much higher and premiums are higher is
because when there is a birth injury a
child is profoundly disabled for the
rest of their life and the recovery is
based on the Life Care needs of that
person it's not because it's a wrongful
death case malpractice premiums in all
of those cases and business
premiums go solely to General negligence
claims they have nothing to do with
wrongful death claims and this statute
will have absolutely no impact on that
um because of that I respectfully spit
that those concerns while they are valid
have nothing to do with the statute so
here what isn't going to happen in if
this statute is enacted and our caps are
raised is um people are going to tell
you the sky is going to fall businesses
are going to run out of the state people
won't be able to get insurance and
that's just not true the state of Maine
in 1997 when we enacted our first cap on
damages of $150,000
had the exact same cap of
$150,000 I suspect that's where we got
our number from when we enacted that
statute since that time Maine increased
their cap to
250,000 then to 500,000 then to 750,000
and now it's at a million as of 2023
with annual increases for
inflation insurance companies have not
left the state of Maine businesses have
not fallen in the state of Maine because
of these changes to their
statute and the reasons that the sky
isn't going to fall are the exact
reasons that our Supreme Court
recognized in 1980 in Carson versus
Moore wrongful death claims are few and
far between very few cases in the state
of New Hampshire ever even reached the
threshold of
$250,000 damage awards are a very small
fraction of insurance premium costs
there are fewer wrongful death cases
than negligence claims in the state
businesses are already considering
negligence claims in their business
decisions we don't have runaway juries
in New Hampshire the New Hampshire jury
system works and if a verdict is excess
of our judges
including uh former Chief Justice Lynn
will reduce that verdict because they
know what is reasonable and what should
be happening in the New Hampshire Civil
Justice System for all of these reasons
I respectfully ask that you vote that
this bill ought to pass when this comes
out of committee and I'm happy to take
any questions you might have
for representative Manos thank you thank
you attorney Haynes I wanted to ask um
regarding loss of Consortium claims what
percentage are settled before suit is
filed what percentage are settled after
suit is filed and what percentage go to
trial so I don't think I can give you
that answer with regard
to even any claims I can tell you the
vast majority do not go to trial
Consortium claims don't exist unless
there is an underlying claim we can't
file suit for a loss of Consortium in
New Hampshire that's just it's not an
independent cause of action so regular
negligence claims the vast majority
probably more than 90% will resolve
before
trial um I asked specifically about the
loss of Consortium because there can
obviously be a negligence claim that
doesn't have a Consortium component to
it you could have uh an unmarried person
who dies without children and um that's
why I phrased it in terms of loss of
Consortium um the other thing I wanted
to know is do you know the total number
of claims that
are um active in any particular year
approximately
um I don't and we actually because this
statute applies just to wrongful death
claims we actually contacted the Circuit
Court Administrative Office in Probate
Court to try to determine that because
that's really the only way and they
weren't able to give us those statistics
sorry representative lonza thank you for
taking my question um I just was curious
I'm not a lawyer so I'm um what is a
runaway uh
verdict well
I don't know if anyone has ever read the
John Grisham novel Runaway Runaway Jury
I I think colloquially people consider
runaway verdicts to be those ones that
you hear about in huge product liability
cases like $56 million or um just
multi-million dollar verdicts that they
just don't happen in New Hampshire
because New Hampshire doesn't allow
punitive or punishment damages to be
granted by a jury right thank
you representative Divine thank you for
taking my question in your opinion why
do you think that we haven't in New
Hampshire raised it to a million instead
of the 500,000 or the
300,000 thank you for your question
representative Divine uh this bill
initially was trying to eliminate the
caps in its entirety which I think would
be the correct outcome here I think
that's what the outcome should be at the
Senate Judiciary Committee hearing there
were suggestions to match Main and habit
a million dollars and I believe it was
just um all of the conversations between
the differing interests um and
stakeholders such as the insurance
companies and different medical and
Health Care associations that the
$500,000 representative Tura thanks and
and thanks for taking the question um so
also not a lawyer
um I it would be helpful to understand a
little bit uh the the other kinds of
Damages that are not covered by this you
sort of mentioned are are there's sort
of a formulaic or economic basis for how
those are
established could you say a word or two
about how loss of Consortium damages are
established and has there ever been any
attempt to sort of say what the right
number is I understanding that that you
think or that you you propose that no
cap would necessarily be but I'm not
sure how these actually
in in practice are set if that question
makes sense thank you for your question
representative um and I'm not sure that
anyone knows how those determinations
are made it's actually within the
province of the jury the jury bases
their decision on their own life
experiences their
own feelings on the value of human life
of spousal relationships of Parental
relationships there is no formula
there's no law there is nothing and uh
our Supreme Court has recognized it
often it's very difficult for a jury to
calculate these subjective types of
Damages because there isn't a formula
for it but we trust jurors and we trust
the jury system to make the right
decision based on their combined
experiences that's why we have a jury of
12 people from different backgrounds
different walks of life different life
experiences who all come together and
they have to reach an agreement based on
their own experiences as to what they
feel the appropriate value should be
follow up follow up yeah um did I
understand you to say that
that judges overseeing these cases do
have the discretion to knock
down uh something that they think is
unreasonable and would in this
circumstance regardless of the cap or or
not they have the power of remor it's
called remor where they can remit or
reduce a jury verdict if the judge finds
it excessive in their discretion
I think it very rarely happens because
most judges will defer to the wisdom of
the jury because our our juries jurors
in new hampture are very conscientious
and thoughtful in the decisions that
they
make any other questions for attorney
Haynes seeing none thank you thank you
thank you Mr chairman good morning to
you all and thank you for allowing me to
speak to you today my name is Joan peso
I'm the president of the big eye of New
Hampshire the New Hampshire Association
of insurance agents repr representing
Independent Insurance Agents throughout
New Hampshire and I'm speaking in strong
opposition to Senate Bill
462 we have all seen our insurance
premiums go up over the last year and
many of you may have heard the term hard
Market from your insurance agent or from
testimony
given insurance has been My Chosen
career since
1979 and although we've had hard markets
in the past this one has been the most
severe there are number of reasons for
the current hard Market but the point of
bringing this up is that every consumer
both on a personal basis and as a
business owner is seeing their insurance
premiums go up this is not the time to
bring legislation that will cause
insurance premiums to go up even
more I understand the point that is
being made about that these caps have
been in place since legislation was
passed in the 90s and a point was made
on the senate floor that that insurance
premiums are going up anyway both are
accurate but by passing this bill or
bills like it we'll make insurance
premiums go up even more it's naive to
think that insurance coverages can be
increased and that's what's happening by
increasing caps and premiums are going
to stay the same insurance carriers
cannot absorb additional exposures
without increasing
premiums and regarding the cap staying
the same since the legislation was put
into place there have been no studies
done here in New Hampshire that would
provide Actuarial data indicating the
Caps are
insufficient much has been said about
New Hampshire having woefully low caps
but when you look at other states many
don't have additional loss of Consortium
coverages like New Hampshire does and
even if New Hampshire caps are lower
than other states it doesn't mean mean
that theirs are right and ours are
wrong I go back to the fact that those
who brought this legislation or brought
this bill forward should have had an
Actuarial study done to show
definitively that the Caps are too low
and that the amount of increase that is
supported by the in by the
study again to my knowledge that has not
been
done I have provided some what I
consider to be very interesting
information on wrongful death
settlements from a law firm here in New
Hampshire these settlements range from a
low of $900,000 to a high of over $4.2
million from another Law Firm the
settlements ranged from a low of $2
million to a high of $15
million ladies and gentlemen having lost
a loved one I know there is no amount of
money that can ease the grief and loss
there is no amount of money that can
compensate for the loss of a child there
just
isn't I was in a meeting recently where
commissioner betancort was the speaker
he made some very good points but one
that applies here he said insurance
company executives are not sitting in
their offices plotting ways to break
into the New Hampshire Insurance Market
we just don't have the volume that would
hit their radar
what we have is a healthy Insurance
environment one where insurance carriers
want to be here offering their products
we shouldn't be making arbitrary changes
to insurance laws that could tip the
scales the other way making New
Hampshire a place where insurance
carriers decide to
leave I respectfully ask that you itl
than a bill
462 or if you're reluctant to do that
that you hold this bill in an interim
study and direct the insurance
department to conduct an Actuarial study
I thank you for your time and I'm happy
to try to answer any
questions any questions for this witness
representative
tur thanks and thanks for taking the
question I it sort of follow on to the
question I asked the previous witness
because you're you're mentioning that
there could or should be an Actuarial
study done to do this I guess given the
sort of morph nature of what the damages
are trying to
achieve what could you say a word about
what an actual aial study would be
seeking to solve um or what what what
what it would be trying to
estimate thank you for the
question what I believe an Actuarial
study would show is number one are the
Caps sufficient are they being
used number two what is the impact going
to be if we don't have an increase in
the cap what is the impact going to be
for insurance premiums or the
availability of insurance
coverages uh if uh at the end of the
study or if this bill was to be put into
law could ask one fult so it sounds like
there's maybe two things actu one is
what the impact on like rates and
premiums would be and the other one
would somehow be trying to estimate
whether or not this is sufficient
whether what what a sufficient I guess
what I'm trying to get it is is there a
way to do a study to see what would be
the right or sufficient uh you know um
place to set this well I'm not an
actuary and I'm not a lawyer so I'll
start there um but I do believe that a
study would give us the background
information um Actuarial are super smart
and the New Hampshire insurance
department has an excellent one right on
staff so I believe that having a study
would give the information that uh that
you as legislators could use to
determine whether the Caps are
sufficient as they are now if they
should be increased or God forbid if
any other questions for this witness
representative Manos thank you thank you
for taking my question um I was just
reviewing the um the uh settlement
compensation list that you attached to
your letter and I was just wondering if
um you could tell us how much of each of
these claims were due to loss of
Consortium I can't tell you that uh when
I was uh doing some research for my
testimony today I was looking for
wrongful death uh settlements because
that is where uh any loss of Consortium
claims would be made is through a
wrongful death so if there was loss of
Consortium and I I would be willing to
Guess that there is in these
settlements um I don't know to what
degree thank
you any other
questions seeing none thank you thank
you very
o'conor good morning Mr chairman members
of the committee thank you for allowing
my testimony this morning um I'm here on
behalf of the New Hampshire Association
for justice uh testifying in support of
the bill um I am with the firm of
Shaheen and Gordon and I've practicing
in the area of workers compensation on
the plaintiff side for 20 years it's
basically the sole focus of my practice
and so my testimony this morning will be
brief uh and will'll address a very
limited narrow issue which is I have
heard concerns or it intimated or argued
that uh passage of this bill will
increase the cost of employers workers
compensation insurance premiums and I'm
just here to testify that that will not
and cannot happen and I want to briefly
explain
why the the entire point of workers
compensation the reason it was initially
passed 100 years ago and has been
existence for that long is to remove the
employees right to sue their employer
for negligence so if an employee dies on
the job due to some risk of their
employment they cannot bring a wrongful
death claim against their employer under
current law which means by definition
their spouse cannot bring an
accompanying loss of Consortium claim um
and you can see this in our workers
compensation statute under Section 281
A8 if you'll forgive me a brief dramatic
reading of the statute what it says is
is that an employee of an employer
subject to this chapter shall be
conclusively presumed to have accepted
the provisions of the chapter and on
behalf of the employee or the employees
personal or legal representatives to
have waved All rights of action whether
at common law or by Statute or provided
under the laws of any other state or
otherwise against the employer or the
employer's insurance carrier so that's
very broad it's deliberately Broad and
it's what's described as the workers's
compensation bar it means that as an
employee you cannot bring a claim so by
definition that is already the state of
the law so an adjustment upwards to the
arbitrary cap that currently exists on
loss of Consortium Claims can have no
effect uh on an employer's workers
compensation
premiums that's that's really all I
wanted to say I'm happy to take any
questions sorry thank you questions for
this
witness seeing none thank you very much
sir thank you next I'm going to call on
Keith Nyan Deputy Commissioner of uh
department thank you Mr chairman members
of the committee um I appreciate the
opportunity to speak today um there are
many experts behind me who I know wish
to speak so I'll try to keep my
testimony short I will kick this off
however by saying without question
premiums will increase in the state of
New Hampshire if this bill passes um I'm
also joined here by my colleague James
Fox who is our director of Property and
Casualty Insurance and our expert
actuary that miss pel referen is also
here should the need come up to ask a
question um we're currently dealing with
a kind of a perfect storm of events in
impacting insurance premiums in the
state of New Hampshire um it was
referenced earlier that catastrophic
weather events are a driver that is by
far one of the biggest we also see
increases in the cost of of repairs
whether it be to Property and Casualty
Insurance like automobile insurance or
homeowners insurance uh there are
litigation costs that always affect
premium rates um in addition there are
supply chain shortages so there are many
different events taking place right now
within the industry that are driving
premiums up we know right now 2024 is
projected to have um all-time highs in
homeowners insurance premiums um what
does this mean so really the industry is
not in a position to absorb yet more
premium increases
um we can certainly talk about the
reinsurance markets but that's going to
be a more drawn out uh discussion again
we do know that litigation costs are one
of the many factors that do drive up um
premiums we just heard from the prior
speaker that workers
compensation um premiums would not be
affected well there are many other types
of insurance as I already alluded to
that would be affected whether it be
homeowners insurance automobile
insurance um commercial liability
medical malpractice insurance any type
of liability insurance um will be
subject to increase premium pressure if
this uh law passes um I want to clude by
saying in the aggregate the markets are
under
stress we really do not want to be
subjecting Insurance consumers in New
Hampshire more stress one of the biggest
roadblocks to to care is cost of
premiums so even as it relates to
medical insurance um increasing those
premiums is what's going to make things
more difficult for our consumers I'm
going to leave it at that and let the
experts behind me um provide their
testimony but I'm happy to answer your
questions representative
Smith thank you very much um I I hear
what you're saying about all these
upward pressures um could you tell I
kind of was a little confused by the
fiscal note and
perhaps someone else could explain it
but I had a question and that had to do
with uh insurance company profits
um from what I have as a lay person seen
um uh s there's certainly some insurance
companies that will be in trouble we
know that but the from what I've seen
ter the largest insurance companies
their profits have increased um
measurably and uh one wonders how you
can equate
that with what you're you know seem to
be indicating of increase in demand I'm
which thank you for your question
representative I think really what we're
touching upon is the formula by which
companies are going to um calculate
their profit margins it also plays into
the reinsurance markets when an
insurance company decides to write
insurance in the state of New Hampshire
there's a formula by which they've
determined they expect to make X doll
profit across their block of
business when the company then begins to
calculate you know each year there's
going to be different well usually
yearly might be by by annually determine
what those rates are going to be they're
going to start off by determining what
that profit margin is going to be and
then they're going to start backing into
that as how they're going to make their
profit which is going to be through
premium increases so if the company
determines through catastrophic losses
where their their claim payments are
going up if through litigation their
claim payments are going up the
adjustment by which companies will hit
their profit goals will be by increasing
those
premiums follow thank you
um in other words we didn't invent the
capitalist system but we just live by
the rules um can can you tell me what
insurance and and please understand that
I don't put myself forward as and you're
all the experts I'm not it's it is an
innocent
question I'm going to let Mr Fox answer
that question it's essentially
self-insurance isn't the type of
insurance that we're speaking about here
but I'll let Mr Fox opine on that thank
you
I would also just say on your first
question you know the one of the issues
we're dealing with is is a hard market
and um what that really means is you
either your insurance is going to be
more expensive to get or you won't be
able to get it or if you are able to get
it you're going to move out of the
admitted Market which is all the
insurance companies that we've all heard
of into the Surplus lines Market or the
alien market so there's there's like a
quality U kind of um uh degrades as the
types of insurance you can get uh and
then one of the other ises that that I
know that we had mentioned the uh C
catastrophic losses for California
Florida really that's the reinsurance so
when you're an insurance company um your
willingness to insure anyone is also uh
contingent upon your ability to buy
insurance to cover those losses so no
Frontline insurer like if you think of
it your auto like aik cut like actually
absorbs all those potential risks they
sell that off to reinsurance companies
which are more International but those
reinsurance companies have kind of
seeded and are much more likely not to
take on things that they view are risky
or and and risky for them is that there
could be a loss there could be many
losses or if we do have losses it's
going to be very expensive so that's
what we mean by a hard market and we're
squarely in a hard market now so that's
a major concern for the Department um
the self- insurance issue is so when we
say in Self Insurance in New Hampshire
some other states they have Self
insurance and it's actually like by
Statute this is what you need to be
self-insured New Hampshire because you
know this way the New Hampshire is the
way uh that just means we don't have
insurance so we cely can't speak to how
this would be handled by people who
don't have insurance whether they would
buy insurance or and decide not to be
self-insured but obviously um if it's
pretty intuitive if if the exposure goes
up you're going to have more losses and
it's going to cost you more money uh to
cover those losses whether you're an
insurance company in a hard Market or uh
a
self-insured I I do have to just ask
what is alien
uh well that that would be like Lloyds
of London so they're from like would
Lloyds of London think it a compliment
to be referred to as alien it's just
it's just how it is it's just how it is
in the industry no they don't they're
not they're not offended by it all right
thank you yeah yes representative foran
um thank you I'm trying to figure out
where the you're we're you're saying
we're we're talking about raising the
cap on this particular type of Damages
and the downside of it is that insurance
premiums would come up but the
counterargument is well but the
value but the people who are injured
will get more damages so like the value
of the of having be able to corre his
damages increases so where's the where's
the tradeoff between um keeping the
premiums low and then on the other hand
raising the value of the insurance I
mean obvious um I guess one danger is if
we raise it too high people won't buy
insurance and then when they cause those
damages they'll go bankrupt or take some
other actions to avoid paying paying the
claim at all since is we are actually
collecting this from the uh from the
defendant not actually from their
insurance company but I'm not sure if I
made myself clear but we're Ser of the
tradeoff between having sufficiently
high levels of Damages a compensa for
loss versus raising the cost of
insurance I mean obviously if we lowered
this to zero
insurance premiums would go down but I
don't think any seriously considering
going going that way so representative
again thank you for the question I I
will try to do my my Best by saying you
know the basic premise of insurance is
that the premiums of the many pay the
claims of a few so in this particular
case you're talking about a fairly High
catastrophic loss in term of litigation
which could be as proposed upward of
$500,000 or if we move the cap you know
Limitless where now you're spreading
that loss over many many people so it's
really
how much do we want to impact the
individual taxpayer to pay for that
isolated loss of
one okay I think understands and also
follow I guess as an Prim Insurance your
mission is also not just to um is also
not just to in uh represent the uh
insurance companies but also like the
people who need insurance I.E the
regular people who need to be insured in
case they cause these damages is that
correct that is correct sir the most
important goal of the department is
consumer protection and making sure that
people can afford those coverage is is
is is is by far our number one goal as
far as a
consumer thank you sir other questions
yes representative M thank you for
taking my question
um in your opinion in comparison to some
of the other states that did raise the
rate of compensation for families or
injured or anybody um placing some sort
of claim
what would you think that the percentage
would
be that people in New Hampshire's
insurance would raise what's the
percentage that you anticipate based on
what other states are doing uh
representative if I understand your
question you are you estimating what
be the percentage that you anticipate
what's your opinion of that what what
what would what do you see the
percentage rate being raised in this
state for you know um Insurance Casualty
Insurance or liability insurance for
individuals in the state what's the
percentage that it would go up for an
individual certainly it's a two-part
answer and I'm going to give I'm sorry
it's a good question with probably a
three-part answer um first and foremost
we already talked about that premiums
are going up in New Hampshire my
recollection from our um recent property
Property and Casualty Symposium was
roughly 10 to 20% premiums are going to
be going up in the home insurance uh
Market um additional to that there was
in the state of New York there was a
similar Bill not identical that had been
passed that that spoke to increasing
litigation limits and that resulted in
11% premium increase um I guess opining
on that that it's not a direct one toone
correlation um we could cut that in half
and say let's assume that this
litigation would go up by 5% that would
be I'm sorry the premiums would go up by
5% % you know that's 5% on top of you
know 10 to 20% it really speaks to um
third part of the response is what Miss
peo had mentioned which is these limits
are being selected or otherwise you know
proposed to be eliminated without any
real Actuarial analysis being done and
certainly the department is all in favor
of um taking time using our Actuarial
resources and Industry resources to
calculate what that premium impact would
be um and that's going to need to be
done on multiple lines of business not
just homeowners not just auto insurance
but the various liability insurance
coverages whether it be medical
malpractice commercial liability Etc we
just don't have that data to give you
the specific answer that I think you
that that you
deserve thank
you I would just add that there's also
the issue we keep saying how how much
premium is going to go up there you know
as stated I think by Joan pasio that
when the commissioner testified at the
last hearing on this you know we're only
.4% of the market and insurance
companies don't need to be in New
Hampshire so if it gets too um if you
become too unattractive for them their
choice also can be just to leave the
state of New Hampshire and and in some
uh lines of business we only have you
know one carrier now or two carriers so
it isn't like uh in Auto it's a very
rich market and homeowners is very rich
but there's other markets that are much
less attractive uh that we don't have a
large number of carriers
handling representative representative
Smith and representative trip thank you
very much I might have misheard here I
am I might have misheard you I thought
know what those figures
are why don't you why don't I mean you
have a wonderful actuar why don't you
know what those figures are why haven't
you set out to find that thank you
representative essentially doing the
type of analysis that we're speaking of
takes time it cannot be done you know
when when the department does a fiscal
note it really talks about the impact of
that particular um bill on the financial
position of the insurance department of
the state um the impact that we're
talking on an industry level takes time
certainly more than what's been allotted
um in in the normal legislative process
um I thank you for the answer and I know
that when you know of course the way the
insurance department is funded differs
from the way many other departments of
funding but this bill was probably
filed 8 months ago maybe more I don't
know um and so it's no
surprise to the department and if you
really want to know the answer and if
you have this wonderful
answer I would just say I'm also the
head of the market conduct unit so this
wouldn't be um it isn't like we just
have the information currently at the
department uh this would be part of
Market conduct um investigation or
examination to gather sufficient
information on on a pretty broad topic
and then have Christian who's here with
us our act try to then determine what
that exactly means and because of the
situation where we hear that there's a
lot of unknowns and variables uh it's a
very complicated process to come up with
an answer to that question uh and uh
also just say that nobody asked us well
I'm I'm not going to belabor it I
understand exactly what you said but by
saying nobody asks you if I
knew the answers to all the um the
questions that are presented to any
Department we wouldn't need executive
branch of the government we would just
settle it all right here the most of
these challenges are serious and they're
hard to know the the answers and the
fact that it's hard to do I would think
that that's what you're supposed to do
wrong representative I feel as though
you know whatever statement I make isn't
going to be satisfy you you know we can
talk about resource issues and
priorities you know relative to all the
insurance markets that we regulate I
really wish we had that answer for you
today we don't we're happy to get it for
you it's just going to take the time
that that we have not invested yet but I
do appreciate the question I I thank you
I thank you very much and it is it is
not uh I don't think it's quite
Justified for you to think that I would
never be happy with an answer I'm happy
with any answer that you give which is
the best that you could give and that's
what I expect thank you thank you
representative
trip thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question uh it's it safe to
assume that uh uh a wrongful death uh
award for a a loss of Consortium is is
usually a component within a
policy it's you don't sell uh wrongful
death uh policies do you
yes that is currently contemplated in
the current
premiums all right so since
uh other people that have testified has
said that uh the New Hampshire
awards
are lower than any other state in the
region I would assume that uh the since
the wrongful death awards are part of a
a comprehensive policy that uh that
policy rates are lower than those other
states is that
true that's logical to believe yes
sir it's logical to believe but is is is
it true or not so representative I would
say knowing that there are many many
factors going into premium
setting I don't know what that
particular variable is we can ask Mr
cell to join us um I don't have that
exact figure but
for wrongful death loss of Consortium
claims is X and all of the other states
around us have no limits or increased
limits logic I'm not the the
mathematician here would certainly
suggest that that particular variable
yes is higher in setting premiums in
those other
states would you'd like to add something
Christian please
I think that that answers the that
question there absolutely there many one
more followup yes please go ahead the uh
CHR not I have to
uh uh that well my training thought
sorry other questions for this W
representative
tur yeah thanks um thanks for taking the
question um so I've asked several
witnesses about Actuarial studies and
the various ways that they're being sort
of proposed here um and it sounds like
you all have the wherewithal internally
to do Actuarial studies on this question
I guess sort of the two-part question is
um do you need any sort of legislative
authority to move forward with any of
that or or to promote that concept of
being done and let me ask both of them
at the same
time is the purpose of an Actuarial
study just to estimate the degree to
which premiums would go up at different
cap levels or is there an Actuarial
approach to look at what the right sort
be no please thank you hi I'm Christian
Cella I'm Chief Property and Casualty
actuary at the New Hampshire insurance
department um Actuarial studies
are challenging um
um the the first Big Challenge in in
trying to tackle such a such a study
would be getting the data all of the
work that I would do and I would need to
get help outside of our department um
would be to get information to get data
um and and that's kind of one of the
problems that we're dealing with in this
situation is that we just have it it is
very hard to know how the effects would
play out if these um caps are raised or
eliminated
and and as I mentioned having data is is
is the beginning of the study and as
mentioned earlier there there was a
question as to how many claims how many
cases are out there either currently or
in recent history that had a loss of
Consortium component and we don't have
that number and so the question is well
who has that
number insurance carriers might have
that number if loss of Consortium is
mentioned in a
settlement um of course jury verdicts
would have that number but as mentioned
we don't even know how many cases are
currently working their way through the
courts and
so long
answer for I would love to do a study
I'd be happy to do a study but I I can't
yet begin a study without data and
that's the challenge follow up yeah
thanks um so just sort of following on
that logic because we've heard a lot
about the idea that we'd like to do a
study and that we maybe could but it
does sound
like the data Maybe is sort of the the
problem um so I guess fundamentally is
this kind of a red herring the idea of
doing an Actuarial study or or would it
would it provide value and I I guess one
thing I'm thinking is we've heard that
you know the non um uh death version of
of the same uh liability doesn't have a
cap and other states have raised their
caps incrementally do we have reference
points that we could that you could use
to to do this so I'm really trying to
get at the feasibility is this something
we should be pursuing as a as a concept
so I I
would yes represent I think you know the
shorter is there there are reference
points um New Hampshire insurance
department is part of the National
Association of Insurance Commissioners
which is as the association name suggest
all 50 states plus territories are part
of this coalition to look at laws and
rules impacting all all jurisdictions we
can reach out to our counterparts
through the National Association and
find some of those Benchmark reference
points that you referred to um
additionally yes we do have um the
authority to initiate that analysis that
we're speaking of um would certainly
create additional work for Mr citarella
but that's part of what we do I don't we
don't need any special mandate from this
committee other than to you know allow
us the time to do that study we would
certainly look at the impact on premiums
we would leverage our industry Partners
in that analysis it might be a fairly
complex data request where we send out
inquiries to every one of our licensed
entities asking for various data points
and then the second part of your
question
was in addition to the impact on premium
I believe you asked
um is it relevant is it appropriate and
then and I'm not wording that properly
but there was a second half of your
question that you would like addressed
in that
analysis yeah I think the distinction I
had asked about was between estimating
the impact on premiums versus Can you
estimate sort of what a a a proper level
for a cap could be for something as
amorphus says as loss of Consortium I
think once representative once the
analysis is done then I think
collectively all of us in this room
would be in a better position to
estimate what the appropriate cap would
be and that's where we get into that
deliberative process working with
industry working with interested parties
to say what is that cap number is it is
it status quo is it you know twice as
much what it is now I think would have
with that data we would be able to make
yep follow up go ahead sorry one more
followup just um it sounds like what
you're suggesting is that this not move
forward at the moment but could move
forward in a future date with more
information do you have a sense of what
the time that it would take to to get
that information would actually
be Christian any idea I apologize you
know um it's easy for me to say three
months but I'm going to get slapped or
kicked under the table so any idea what
I I can say what the analysis part would
take you know um yep I mean as mentioned
the difficult part would be getting the
information and we would need to work
with as as the Deputy Commissioner
mentioned we would have to work with our
industry Partners to get that
information we would look for
cooperation from The Trial Lawyers
um let's put it this way once we get the
information 90 days I think would be
ample to do the actual Actuarial work
you know I think that's
reasonable that's a very good question
representative testerman you had a
question wa okay any any other questions
so I guess I oh I'm sorry represent
ahead what do you need from
us to I mean I I wish the commissioner
were here I haven't seen him in a while
nice to see him um
what do you need from
us for the commissioner and the rest of
you in the
department to
work time representative you know it's
really the the Mandate of yes we value
your input please take the time come
back to us we can set a time period
whether it be 3 months or 6 months um
and ask us to come back with the numbers
that you
request so it would I hate to say the
word mandate but authorization or
direction to move in that to move in
that direction for you I I I appreciate
your CER it makes me sad because I would
have hoped that you would do this on
your own but I think what I hear you
saying is unless we
unless the legislature directs you to do
this um it would not necessarily find a
place on your to-do
list thank you for the question I guess
at the risk of saying probably a little
bit too much um most state agencies like
most businesses deal with resource
issues Mr cell is very busy um we
recently have made we we are filling out
our ranks of actuaries so we will have
more resources next next month month
after to assist in that it it's resourc
driven and we need
to direct Mr citarella where to to to
put his efforts and this will certainly
help us prioritize this matter over
other things that we could be working on
could may I also risk but but if we were
to do that does that then mean that we
are displacing
other
work that you would left to your own
devices considered to be more important
than
this I again I'm G to risk uh saying too
much but maybe the commissioner might
um ultimately this is a policy decision
made by the legislature as to caps on
the
department has a
position right now that
says right now at this point in time
there's a lot of pressure you've heard
it again a lot of pressure upward
pressure on premiums it is a hard Market
in most lines of business certainly
commercial liability coverage whether
that be professional liability coverage
products liability coverage other
liability general liability coverage in
the commercial this is going to affect
those lines most most notably and I
think
intuitively so if there is if there is
concern as to how that is going to
affect and try to make a a a a
quantitative
estimate if I were to do that I would
need information in order to feel
comfortable making put a number on it um
I think I and I speak for think I speak
for the commissioner for the Department
where we kind of hoped it didn't it it
it might not it wouldn't have to come to
that that there might
be um a reasonable compromise at some
smaller you
know cap temporary or time limited cap
so that the hard Market might
dissipate um if there is and if there is
a
legislative question like from the
hearing from a legis
it makes it easier for us it's not
necessary as the deputy mentioned but it
makes it easier for us to then go to
carriers and say hey we need your help I
need this information we have a you know
we have a bill that's pending we have
legislators that are waiting for this
answer we need cooperation I need I need
the
data that would move things along um
long answer
um many different variables you know in
play but you know six months from now it
would be easier to have a number for
you other questions for the yes
representative Ms thank you thank you
for taking my questions um we heard
earlier today that about 90% of cases
are settled um without um I can't
remember whether it was prior to filing
suit or or before trial but 90% of cases
settle um and one could anticipate or
surmise that there are non-disclosure
agreements or um confidentiality
agreements and those kinds of
settlements and I'm wondering
whether uh assuming that's true whether
that would impact your ability to get
the data that you need to then do the
Actuarial
analysis it's an excellent question I
don't believe it would those
confidentiality Agreements are certainly
specific to the parties involved I
believe we can actually request the data
in in unidentifiable format so that we
can get the genericized data if you will
I believe we can answer that for
you other questions for this witness
representative Perez I apologize I was
late so you may have answered this it's
my understanding that many states have
this uh and they have much higher limits
than we have presently in New Hampshire
because ours are quite low I think on
the very very low and they haven't been
changed I believe since
1997 so how are other states handling
this when they have them up to a million
bills can you put on
premiums I think it's intuitive that it
affects premium how different insurance
companies approach that is handled
differently by different insurance
companies some insurance comp companies
may very well say hey there is a new new
law new cap we've worked under this
prior cap and with that assumption when
we set our rates last year this new year
new
caps we're going to change our rates and
premiums accordingly some insurance
companies will handle it differently
some insurance companies will say okay
let's wait to see how it affects
settlements how it you know whether more
more claims go to a jury um and then in
three to five years we'll see how our
experience plays out and then we'll
adjust premiums at that time insurance
carriers are are afforded that ability
to handle that situation as as they deem
fit and it would be reasonable to to
believe that some might change their
rates
immediately yes so you don't have um uh
any idea or you haven't done any looking
into and saying so this state went up
and their rate this state increased
theirs and this is a very modest
compared to other states I understand
how much their rates went up so we don't
know you know oh the rates went up by
50% so you don't have any of that data
um no and that would be difficult to
ascertain just because there are many
many factors that go in into a a raate
filing that you know may result in an
increase you know the situation in Maine
it was somewhat gradual you know it
appeared as if that there were step
increases every few years and that the
most recent one went from 750 to a
million dollars at that
level you're you're going to it it would
not be surprising to see less of an
effect than it would be to you know in
this case more than triple the
um the
cap I at least that's that's an that
that's that would not be a surprise that
there would be less of an impact or an
immediate impact in in that situation
yeah other questions for this witness
yes I just have one question it's
my my perception and correct me if I'm
wrong that
this we're arguing over what is
generally a a relatively I mean it seems
like we're arguing over the tail rather
than the dog in the sense that the
there's no cap on the on the wrongful
death claim itself right and typically I
would think the that will
be the
Big Driver of the amount of of a verdict
or settlement and the and the loss of
Consortium would be a relatively smaller
percent of that and so just
wondering um I mean is that is that
generally true that you know we're we're
arguing over something that is is a
really uh relatively small percentage of
the of most damage claims sir I think
you said that quite well okay that that
yes that is the bigger issue without
question you know really when when our
testimony is really to indicate that yes
premiums would go up and I
believe and there's individuals behind
me who can give you data that the
essence of your point is spot on that
the the wrongful death claim is
certainly going to far exceed the loss
of Consortium component of any
settlement other questions thank you
very much see none thank you thank you
folks uh I see Mr Fox I you signed a
card and I I appreciate that is there
anything else that you want okay no
that's fine thank you right uh Marissa
Chase
please good afternoon m u Mr chair
members of the committee thank you for
the opportunity to speak to for the
record my name is Marissa Chase I'm the
executive director for the New Hampshire
Association for justice which is a
Statewide Professional Association of
trial attorneys what I just submitted I
left I had left over in my backpack from
the Senate hearing from one of our
members who um had a very tragic um case
um involving a loss of Consortium claims
so I thought while I had it and he went
through the trouble to print it out on
fancy paper I would give it to you all
um I just wanted to address a few points
and I want to Echo everything that Holly
Haynes had said earlier and for those of
you that were not able to um be here for
her testimony I I hope that you will go
back and watch um her presentation I
think those of you who are here will
agree that it was quite compelling and
illustrative of how these claims work
um we have spent so much time on this
one piece of legislation that is in my
mind just an issue of fundamental
fairness you have the situation where um
a defendant would rather see a dead
plaintiff than a catastrophically
injured one why are those two scenarios
treated so differently if you
effectively lose your spouse and
enjoyment of their life versus if they
are actually deceased um and that's what
this bill seeks to remedy I do think
this legislation would not have any sea
change of impact on how litigation works
even if the cap were completely
eliminated but knowing that there were a
lot of concerns out there the felt more
comfortable with trying to come to a
lower number and trying to get all the
parties together we were very willing to
negotiate and
um I will not speak for anyone
else
um again I just want to reiterate this
is the only cap that exists in any
elements of these
claims and as someone noted earlier the
claim for loss of Consortium in a
wrongful death case would hope be few
and far between because hopefully there
aren't many um instances every year of
people getting killed by the negligence
of someone else and having a viable loss
of Consortium claim as a derivative of
that underlying claim again this is a
derivative claim so if the policy limit
against the defendant is maxed out by
the underlying negligence claim there is
no claim for loss of Consortium this is
not this is not a big deal um two other
points I wanted to say um I actually do
have data from other states and I sent
it to you all um you know in in Illinois
when they raised and then eliminated
their
caps liability insurance rates actually
decreased over the next
decade in Maine they just when they
incrementally increased their caps and
now it's at a million dollars did a
comparison with the rest of the market
that is in your inboxes as well stayed
generally the same um litigate it's my
understanding and I'm not an actuary and
I don't represent an insurance company
but what happens in litigation does not
I want to be careful about this word
does not drive the insurance Market I
also know that there is this talk about
a hardening Market that issue has been
raised by the insurance industry since
about
2019 um yet at the same time as
representative Smith noted earlier the
profits that insurance companies are
making across the country today have
increased
exponentially so I don't know where the
need to raise premiums necessarily comes
from
um two other points I wanted to make um
again um when this was instituted over
the um over 1997 1998 um when this
became a cause of action 25 years ago I
was in first grade and we haven't even
looked at those caps
since
um um representative Manos had asked
about the number of these cases that
exist per year um
because it's a wrongful death
action it was it's my understanding from
our members behind me that in order to
open up in a state to file a wrongful
death action you must file a rule eight
Motion in Probate Court and
representative Lynn please correct me
one I'm wrong um so I asked the
administrative office of the Courts for
that number of how many rule eight
motions were filed on an annual basis to
try to get some sense of how many
wrongful death claims even exist that
would not include loss of consortion but
just give the large larest possible
number and they indicated they do not
keep track of that information so I'm
sorry I don't have that for you um in
terms of um representative lonza earlier
you asked about Runaway Jury verdicts
our organization has a list serve um
that acts as a tool for all of our
members to ask each other questions it's
especially helpful for smaller law
firms a couple weeks ago our list serve
was a buzz because there was the rare
plaintiff's verdict in a personal injury
claim in Hillsboro South in Nashua um by
Dave goddman that verdict was for
$150,000 and our members were
celebrating that there was even a
plaintiff's jury verdict that came out
of Hillsboro South we do not have
frivolous lawsuits we don't have large
Awards and payouts in New Hampshire
because we're cheap Yankees
um let's see I just want to under make
sure I hit everyone's questions um so we
do have the data from other states that
you know I don't I think it's kind of an
impossible task to predict the future
when we don't know how many people are
going to be killed by the negligence of
others and setting rates but we can look
historically at what has happened in
other states that went forward with
raising or eliminating their caps and
those across the board show that rates
have either stayed the same or decreased
depending on National
Trends
um The Grieving families act in New York
that was um mentioned a bill that passed
in New York was actually vetoed by
Governor hokel so I don't know um and
that act changed the um statute of limit
so it passed through the New York
legislature that in expanded the scope
of LW of Consortium claims who could
bring them increase the statu of
limitations increased the amounts it did
a whole lot this bill is absolutely not
B this bill changes a number does not
change the scope who can bring claims in
what time frame they can bring claims
and again was vetoed so it has not been
enacted so if rates are increasing in
Maine it's not because of anything to do
with loss of
Consortium
um um I also want to say to the point of
how much time it's going to take to get
the Actuarial information I just looked
back through my email and um found notes
that I took from a meeting we had with
the Department of Insurance and some of
my members on January 26th so this bill
has been around for a while if we needed
to gather more data it went from from
Senate Judiciary Committee there was a
public hearing it passed the Senate then
it was referred to Senate finance and
there was an ability to take a look at
any fiscal impact there there was no
testimony um it passed out of Senate
finance and it passed the Senate came to
the house and now there's a fiscal note
um so we we have had the opportunity
over months to look at any real hard
data points that we could point to that
says that this is going to you know
again make the sky fall and I just don't
see it so I will end my testimony there
thank you for your time and
consideration I'm happy to answer any
questions questions for this
witness seeing none thank you thank you
good afternoon Mr chairman and members
of the committee I'm Kiren Schultz I'm
here with my with my colleague Jim hadam
we're both attorneys uh with Nix and
peepy um we're here representing
presenting State Farm which is one of
the leading writers of auto and home
insurance in the nation and here in New
Hampshire and we're here in opposition
to SB
462 the reasons for our opposition of
the bill largely track uh what you've
heard already as far as concerns from
other insurance IND industry
stakeholders and what you're what you
will hear from others after us um we've
just submitted written testimony for the
record and I'll summarize its main
points briefly
every human life is priceless and the
current law in New Hampshire
appropriately recognizes that our
current law protects the interests of
individuals who seek relief through the
Civil Justice System after they've lost
a loved one a loss which is intangible
non-pecuniary
um it's it's really an emotional loss
and the emotional or amorphous nature of
that loss makes quantifying the damages
difficult
our current law also uh you know for all
of the people in New Hampshire who
purchase insurance the law protects
Market stability and predictability and
that's really
important so in a wrongful death action
in New Hampshire the way it is now um
the law allows at deance estate to
recover significant categories of both
economic and non-economic damages which
are not capped
these damages flow through the estate to
compensate the decedent next of kin the
beneficiaries heirs at law without any
limitation on the amount of an award and
the Trier of fact is entrusted
appropriately with assessing those
damages what attributes to consider when
an estate seeks compensation for its
losses resulting from a decedent's
injury and
death and then similarly subject to
reasonable caps New Hampshire law allows
damages for wrongful death claims
related to the loss of a relationship
with the loved one so these lost
Consortium claims uh the when when the
loss is caused by untimely death due to
negligence or other
misconduct and we believe the current
law in New Hampshire strikes the right
balance on this really tough
subject um it permits meaningful
compensation for family members economic
and non-economic damages and when you
consider the totality of the recoverable
damages for wrongful death and lost
Consortium and on appropriate facts the
surviving family members might also be
able to bring claims for example U
negligent or intentional infliction of
emotional
distress the availability of
compensation for these claims puts New
Hampshire well within the mainstream
nationally
um and as we've discussed a little bit
uh questions from Representatives tour
and and Manos I believe about um the
data that might be available uh how
these Actuarial studies might be
conducted conducted uh it you know
accurate and
comprehensive publicly available data on
wrongful death Awards is really
difficult to get um these cases are most
often settled the fact of settlement is
confidential the am of settlement is
confidential um and very few of them are
actually ever filed in court it seems
and then even fewer ever make it to a
jury uh or a tri of fact or to a
verdict
um we know that wrongful death claims
are relatively low
frequency but High severity claims um by
that I mean that wrongful death claims
are less common than uh non-death
personal injury claims but the wrongful
death claims result in substantially
payouts and so we believe that
increasing the Caps as this bill
proposes to do uh risks materially
impacting insurance rates potentially
driving them up even higher uh it also
risks driving up the volume of lawsuits
and settlements whether meritorious or
non-meritorious
and it risks striving up the ultimate
payouts of resulting Awards by
businesses and insurers and for these
reasons we oppose the bill and I believe
um my colleague Jim hayam has some some
more data points about um rates if if uh
we'd like to present that testimony
certainly Mr
ha so thank you Mr chair Again Jim hayam
representing State Farm for the record
um so you know I in the Senate heard a
lot of questions and concerns about you
know if this is going to Impact
Insurance rates and premiums paid you
know how much is that going to be and we
certainly heard that frustration uh from
this committee that um you know there
hasn't been
information this available uh and but
knowing something about how axies
operate I Echo what I think you heard
earlier about how what a complicated
analysis it would be um but I did ask
State Farm if they could just give me an
estimate for purpose of this hearing as
to what they would anticipate their rate
increases would be now you need to
remember that State Farm is an auto
carrier so that's the most important
line or it's primarily an auto carrier
and a homeowner's carrier so we're
talking about the rate impact for
automobile policies in New Hampshire and
what State Farm estimate estimates is
that an additional 30 to
$45 of Premium per automobile policy
which is the equivalent of an additional
4% of Premium if this bill passes so
again I remind you there's you know
State Farm is one of a 100 or so maybe
more companies that ride in New
Hampshire so this is just a reflection
of what State Farm would do um and but
we also need to keep in mind that um you
know the impact on other types of
commercial lines um liability coverages
particularly medical malpractice would
likely have a much more dramatic uh
impact negative impact on the rates and
the premiums charged so I just wanted to
add that to this uh discussion and I'm
happy to take any questions thank you
questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
thank you next I'm going to call on Ann
good afternoon chairman good afternoon
Representatives um my name is an CI uh I
am with the law firm shardi and bacon
out of their Boston office um and I'm
here to testify an opposition of this
bill on behalf of the American tort
reform Association which is a
broad-based coalition of businesses
municipalities associations and
professional firms with an interest in
promoting greater balance and
predictability in civil litigation and I
apologize to you ahead of time I'm a
fish out of water because my day job is
I'm a
litigator fair
warning my hope today is to provide you
um some context for New Hampshire's loss
of Consortium caps as they pertain to
wrongful death claims context which
hopefully will highlight why the current
caps ought to remain in place the
current caps keep New Hampshire's law on
loss of Consortium recovery in the
mainstream as to a broader picture Most
states allow for some form of loss of
Consortium arising from wrongful death
uh and these might include some or all
of the following uh recovery by a child
for the loss of a parent recovery by a
parent for loss of a child and spousal
Consortium um some states only recognize
spousal
Consortium uh and other states don't
allow for Recovery of loss of Consortium
in any form at all uh in the context of
wrongful death New Hampshire allows for
all three forms of loss of
Consortium what's more of the states who
do allow for loss of consor and wrongful
death about a dozen only allow for
pecuniary Recovery which I believe has
come up earlier uh that's to say that
these states allow for Recovery as to
the amounts that can be certainly or at
least Le somewhat reasonably
ascertained in other words loss of
Consortium in these states is limited to
economic harm like the loss of the VA
the value of the decedent labor for
instance as opposed to emotional loss in
contrast New Hampshire's loss of
Consortium statute allows for subjective
recovery like loss of comfort affection
guidance companionship and it does with
the tradeoff of these caps
but perhaps most importantly we ought to
keep in mind that loss loss of
Consortium the one at issue is
derivative of a claim for wrongful death
and put plainly recovery for loss of
Consortium is in addition to that of the
underlying claim for wrongful death and
in a decedent estate the party bringing
the wrongful death action has the
ability to recover for the mental and
physical pain and suffering suffered by
the decedent which is non-economic the
decedent's Lost earning capacity the
decedent's probable duration of life but
for the injury and reasonable expenses
such as medical bills or funeral
expenses incurred by the estate on
account of the wrongful death but that's
not all New Hampshire is one of only a
few States I think there are only six
that allows for something called honic
damages and honic damages are sometimes
referred to as loss of enjoyment of Life
damages and these esoterically named
damages are notably
uncapped to be clear currently in no
hampsh in New Hampshire there is no
limit to the non-economic recovery in a
state can seek for a decedent's loss of
enjoyment of Life the only limits are
those on the loss of Consortium claims
ones that are only recoverable in
addition to the the already uncapped
possible recovery for the wrongful death
itself so taking a step back to view the
statute in its entirety reveals that not
only does the legislature not need to
raise caps on these derivative claims it
should not after all raising these
claims could run the risk of confusing
juries into rewarding duplicative
recovery to be clear this is not an
indictment on New Hampshire juries this
is just the opposite this is a nuanced
area of the law one that attorneys
and that's to say that people who for
whatever reason signed up to discuss and
argue things like konic damages struggle
to make sense of so viewed in the
context of the wrongful death statute
the Caps as they exist make sense in
fact we submit that it's the current
caps on these damages that helps keep
New Hampshire in the
mainstream the current caps are
reasonable controls on highly subjective
damages and as to Total Recovery there
appears to be no evidence that
plaintiffs in New Hampshire are not
already getting appropriate Awards
indeed a quick review of New Hampshire
plaintiffs firm's websites reveal
Council boasting about wrongful death
settlement Awards some crusting $4
million and again this is
settlement I submit to you that none of
my friends across the courtroom would
argue that raising caps on these loss of
Consortium claims would not cause them
to raise their bottom lines at the time
of settlement
negotiations for all of these reasons I
respectfully request the committee
reject this bill I thank you very much
for your time and I'll answer any
questions that I can help questions for
this
witness yes representative
Forest thank you thanks for taking my
question so here's a concern I have okay
we have a wrongful death and I file a
suit here in New Hampshire and the
attorney says well we're going to give
you 2
million um and it's going to cover you
know uh loss of wages blah blah blah but
if you want to get for loss of
Consortium then you have to file that
bill separately so we don't know how
much they actually get for each of the
different things we would know that loss
of wages potential wages would be very
documented correct um that type of thing
but would those say in them would the
settlement saying them and this is
because they're not going to have their
L run around anymore that's a great
question representative um generally
when you're talking about
settlements um they generally are not
divided out like that um settlements I
think as others have discussed are
usually highly
confidential um there are more um for
lack of a better term legal jargon
Clauses that you would imagine are in
there exact so you understand
Representatives yes there's there's a
there's a whole host of um legal jargon
in these settlement agreements but
generally they are not parceled out um
to the degree that you're talking about
in
settlement yep so you're saying that we
have no idea if they received any
compensation for that particular portion
of the list of things that New Hampshire
allows I see that's no that's a good
question so that would be um something
that the attorneys would discuss back
and forth
um the the plaintiff's attorneys
advocating for the plaintiff's side will
question yeah representative CH yeah
thank you thanks for taking the question
thank you um and maybe I misunderstood I
just wanted to clarify something that I
thought you heard earlier I had asked
sort of how these damages for loss of
Consortium are are generally derived and
it sounds I was understood that there
really is it's just purely subjective
based on experience I thought you had
said in New Hampshire there are more
guidelines around how those are created
and I'm not sure if that was I heard
that correctly no I'm sorry if I if I
said that I misspoke you're correct they
are highly subjective the loss of
Consortium um the loss of Consortium
recovery in New Hampshire uh is much
more subjective whereas in certain other
states um the statute may say for XYZ
and nothing else um you can recover in
New Hampshire for highly subjective
things like affection Comfort Etc okay
so it's other states that place these
these limits on it okay thank you other
questions for this witness yes I have
one question
the why does it make any sense to to
sort of follow up on Miss Chase's
testimonial why does it make any sense
for New Hampshire to say there will be a
cap on the limit of Consortium damages
in a wrongful death case but if instead
of uh Tor feaser killing someone they
just you
know uh injure him for life in a very
significant way but he or she is alive
there's no there's no limitation no it's
it's a very good question chairman um I
here only on on behalf of this specific
bill and I realize that there has been
discussion about um the other but as to
as to wrongful death specifically um I
think our fear would be double
recovery um as as as far as uh loss of
Consortium goes on top of the uncapped
wrongful
death right but I mean that same double
recovery would exist where somebody
didn't
die it's very true okay yes chairman
other yes represent
stapled thank you for taking my question
thank you
representative an example here
um a woman dies in an automobile
accident
not her
fault um she is the caregiver to a
dementia Alzheimer's person as a result
he's got to go
into um assisted living or nursing home
whatever is that case uh one of wrongful
death uh or Consortium or
both it's it's a very good question
representative um it of course my my
lawyer self says it depends on how the
complaint reads right so if you were the
plaintiff's council you can you can lay
your claims out as you wish um but uh to
I think to your question is to and as to
recovery
specifically um you know our our
position would be there is a uh a there
is a tall order to ask of juries to
parcel out your hypothetical and say
okay how would you award the wrongful
death how would you award the loss of
Consortium um again I think it is it's
something that me and my colleagues
debate um damages and and the like and
it it gets very very nebulous and very
very nuanced so it's hard to
answer sure thank you other questions
being none thank you very much thank you
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee my name is Ben for the record
my name is Ben Bradley I'm the vice
president of state government
relations for the New Hampshire Hospital
Association I hope to provide some
perspective on uh our members concerns
uh as part of the broader
discussion um the association is opposed
to S SP 462 I'm not going to read my
whole testimony I will submit it for the
record but I would like to make a few
points for our Healthcare System system
to continue functioning effectively we
believe the existing reasonable limits
on liability must be sustained and I'll
tell you why we acknowledge all victims
of medical malpractice should have
access to the courts for the
compensation they're entitled to under
our laws medical liability is a subset
of a larger category of Industries
affected by this bill things like kids
camps other
nonprofits businesses anybody is a
purchaser of liability insurance I hope
my my testimony on behalf of hospitals
in New Hampshire is included in your
consideration of the broader scope of
stakeholders this bill
effects if s SP 462 is amended by the
Senate became law we believe all
Insurance buying consumers including but
not limited to hospitals and Healthcare
Providers would experience higher
premiums leading to higher health care
costs as noted by the Commissioner of
Insurance on several occasions and as
noted in the fiscal
note increased medical liability will
influence where providers decide to
practice their chosen specialty and what
procedures they're comfortable with
performing this upward pressure on
medical liability has a chilling effect
on providers of high-risk services and
most notably we believe obstetric and
labor and delivery services although
there are contributors many contributors
to the closure of 11 birthing units in
New Hampshire since 2003 and inability
to secure and afford malpractice
insurance is a leading driver of their
closures just last year the owner of the
conquered birthing center indicated
publicly that the reason for her closure
in July was because of a huge increase
in the price of malpractice insurance
additionally just last year the state of
Maine as we've heard increased their am
uh wrongful death loss of Consortium
claims award
caps um in September a month before
those caps were due to go into effect
York hospital closed their labor and
delivery units the fragility of our
labor and delivery services in our area
could not be more evident than these two
examples however there is one additional
scenario playing out in our North
Country where there is only one labor
and delivery unit in all of Coos County
they are currently well staffed with a
team of providers and remain committed
to providing access to uh maternal
care however their biggest concern
threatening access to their care is an
increase in medical liability insurance
I caution the committee s SP 462 may be
well intentioned but could be the straw
that breaks the camels back for many
Specialties and industries at which time
those affected may need taxpayer support
to maintain their operations this exact
scenario has played out in New York
state where from 2003 to 2013
malpractice premiums increased by
60% to stem the loss of doctors leaving
their practice or moving to other
jurisdictions New York State enacted
legislation subsidizing the malpractice
insurance costs of
doctors I have outlined in my testimony
reference to a US Chamber of Commerce
study on uh on on the cost of
malpractice in each state New Hampshire
already has the highest cost for medical
Li liability at $88 million among states
Vermont Maine Ro and Rhode Island each
$29 million $65 million and $60 million
respectively New Hampshire is $88
million in this study the total cost in
that study per household was
$2,190 a
year the historic closures of several
labor and delivery units in New
Hampshire the scenario playing out in
our North Country and any other
circumstances that would affect be
affected by an increase in wrongful
death loss of Consortium cases is why
the New Hampshire Hospital Association
cannot support any increase in the caps
for wrongful for damages to wrongful
death loss of
Consortium Awards please consider the
unintended consequences of this bill I
ask you to put a lot of thought towards
this before moving it through the
legislature uh and we would ask the
committee to move the bill in expedient
to legisl
thank you thank you questions for this
witness seeing none thank you sir Mora
Weston
please good afternoon members of the
committee for the record my name is Mora
Weston I am here today on behalf of DMC
Primary Care DMC Primary Care is an
independent physician-owned family
medical practice serving approximately
70,000 patients in at least seven
communities on an annual basis our 70
Primary Care Providers manage more than
225,000 patient
appointments DMC Prides itself on being
a high quality lower cost provider with
same day access to care for our
patients I'm here today on their behalf
and opposition to Senate Bill
462 we believe that Senate Bill 462
would have the effect of increasing the
number of claims against our
practitioners where they're meritorious
or not the potential for increases in
claims and litigation would have the
effect of increasing our insurance
premiums this has a direct cost on our
business at a time when access to
Primary Care is critical we cannot
support a proposal that could negatively
impact our ability to deliver primary
care and other healthc care services at
our current
rates we believe that as you evaluate
the potential merits of such a policy
change all potential consequences should
be evaluated including the consequences
for independent Primary Care
we would like to continue to offer
robust access to Primary Care at the
lowest possible costs we would recommend
this bill be inexpedient to legislate
and I'm happy to answer questions if I'm
able thank you questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
next
James um
Marston not sure if I pronounced that
correctly if I did I if I did not I
apologize
I was way off but that's my fault
because I was writing in the hallway in
the card I'm James Monahan with the I'm
here today on behalf of the New
Hampshire Association of counties I'll
hand in a letter from the association um
but to summarize it uh it uh Echoes much
of what you've heard from the those who
testified today about the upward
pressure on rates associated with uh the
passage of the legislation um in large
measure I think the the role we can play
here is to remind the committee that uh
it is public entities that would be
impacted by um by these changes as well
as the private voices you've heard from
today with that I'm I know it's well
into the hearing I'm happy to answer any
questions you might have or provide
additional information if the committee
needs it yeah uh representative
representative Smith thank you um good
afternoon M Mr Monahan could you answer
a question for me and maybe you can
you're now guess the third person in a
row who's you know talked about all this
upward pressure that you want to try to
avoid um if New Hampshire
already is so high in terms of how how
is it worded here let me see um uh the
highest cost to Medical
liability
um when
and if that exists now under current
pressure a current situ why would you
say that it's going to go
higher if in
fact the cap is eliminated or raised
when other states have the
Caps I'm not asking the question clearly
am I Mr
vahan and I understand that you're a lot
SM than I am about it I just don't I
mean I see something of the
child uh the childhood story book of
Henny Penney the sky is
falling in these
discussions I don't quite get the
relationship between what the situation
is now and what it would
become if we tend to conform to what
other states are
doing was Henny Penney a hen
yes yes but it could be you know a
chicken or a hen it really doesn't
matter the whole principle is that the
sky was not falling but Henny peny
short predicted everybody that the sky
was falling yeah I'm certainly not an
underwriter or Healthcare Economist and
so that's why I think the association
was careful in this testimony which I
haven't handed out I apologize um to not
be over dramatic about you you know what
might be perceived impacts but to
observe that there were up upward
pressures uh we struggled to look at the
bill and see how it would cause downward
pressure on rates but I can certainly
speak with some of the county
administrators and nursing Hill
administrators who are responsible for
uh for ensuring the county against um
losses and exposure and rful death and
and just one quick thank you very much
um are do the counties self-insure for
any of this thank the answerers no um on
that whe How each individual County's uh
insurance premium is structured um I
would um need a little bit of time to
get back to you on that but I think for
the most part uh they are you know
primex for example is uh you know the
leading leading writer of uh right uh
insurance for the for the counties thank
you and we do know the history of of how
of what has happened over the years in
um municipalities great nonprofits you
know partner for the the counties and
municipal government right thank you
very much for educating me on that okay
other questions for this witness seeing
thank you Mr chairman thank you members
of the committee my name is George
russos I'm a lawyer with Orin Reno and
conquered and I'm here on behalf of two
Insurance trade associations uh the
American Council
uh of uh property
insurance uh Association
apcia apcia uh did submit some testimony
to you by email yesterday I hope you
have a a chance to look at it and also
the New Hampshire Association of
domestic insurance companies which is a
more local trade Association together
these clients write most of the Property
and Casualty Insurance that's written in
the state of New Hampshire we are very
concerned about this
bill I know it's been a very long
hearing uh you've been very patient and
maintaining interest in it uh I will try
to be brief but there are some points I
think that are important to make there
have been it's one thing to have a
policy disagreement about where Cap
should be and what's fair it's another
to disagree about the facts and the
primary disagreement that I've heard
today is the trial lawyer is saying to
you that this will not increase premiums
the insurance department uh in its
testimony and its fiscal note saying
that they're very concerned about the
increase in premiums that this bill
would uh
produce and the concerns that others uh
have uh expressed about what the effect
on their premiums would be if this bill
were to
pass there's a way to resolve that
dispute um the uh experts on uh pricing
of insurance are not the trial
lawyers um they are more the insurance
department and within in the insurance
department the this field is Insurance
Actuarial work that whose function it is
to look at circumstances and predict
what future losses will be now this bill
did not come up out of nowhere in New
Hampshire it's part of a national effort
that was uh bills were proposed in 11
states some in the last couple of years
some states have enacted them States
like New York pass a bill but Governor
Hershel vetoed that bill out of concerns
for the cost of the increase in New York
uh Maryland uh had a similar proposal to
raise its caps and that bill was
defeated uh in Maryland
recently in both Maryland and New York
the legislature had a the benefit of
actual orial studies that predicted what
the loss would be in New Hampshire
milman did a
study uh and a acttion o firm in
Maryland also did exactly what uh is the
subject of uh your inquiry today what
would this bill do to Insurance costs
how it will affect the nonprofits the
hospitals and the businesses in the
state that are doing business and that
question is
answerable um I should mention uh Mr
chairman that this bill was filed as a
confidential bill and we didn't find out
about it and I don't think anyone else
did until uh shortly before not long
before the hearing no one in the senate
had asked us or anybody uh to quantify
the cost of the bill they've represented
that it won't cost anything you know can
I can I just interrupt for a second Mr R
did I I want to make sure I I think you
might have misspoken or maybe I
misunderstood but did you say that
Millum had done a study of New Hampshire
rates no if I did I I I I have misspoken
mman The asial Firm did a study in New
York of the effect on rates in New York
and In fairness it should be said that
uh the the uh apples and apples
comparison is not easy because New York
has very restrictive uh recoveries right
now unlike New Hampshire so the effect
in New York one might guess is is going
to be greater than the the premium
effect uh in New Hampshire but that
remains to be seen
and in the study and melan if I recall
correctly uh the projected increase in
New York uh if his bill went through was
something like an average of 11%
slightly higher for self- insurance
increase of costs and again I I'd be
happy to provide you the the study if
you'd be interested in seeing it but I I
think it was as high as a 40% uh
increase on medical malpractice premiums
that was that was projected in New York
so because of of that the governor in in
New York vetoed that
bill
so the first question I think is what is
the cost and I think the answer is let's
find out the cost before uh the
legislature goes ahead and makes a
judgment about passing this bill this
bill by the way uh is not just an
increase to cover the cost of living
but the increase I'm looking at line 15
of the bill
in spousal Consortium claims is from
$150,000 to
$500,000 and the increase in parent
child claims would rise from
$50,000 to
$300,000 so to follow the example of one
of the Witnesses in favor of this
bill the consequence of this bill with
four children and a spouse the increase
would be $1.3 million higher than what
is allowed under current law in that
particular
case
so how can you not say that this is
going to increase costs it may be uh a
low frequency uh occurrence but it's a
high severity occurrence to use uh
Insurance terms
so the next point that is
suggested uh is that we're an outlier
somehow we're very cheap in what we
award to uh parents and and uh children
and spouses and that's just not true um
we do have as is pointed out low um caps
relative to some other states but some
states do not allow an action
uh for Consortium or for parent child at
all if you look and we've asked people
to do that to to look beyond
the the surface and evaluate overall in
wrongful death cases where does New
Hampshire stand relative to other states
and the conclusion is that we're in the
mainstream of States some are higher
some neighboring states are higher but
many are were somewhere in the
mainstream is the conclusion again I can
provide you more detail if you want that
but don't think that uh just because one
element of the recoveries is limited
more than some other states do that we
do not compensate people adequately uh
in wrongful death
cases and to that end again I know it's
late but there are three parts of this
bill the first part is wrongful death
claims that the estate can bring
and that is money that is shared by the
the surviving spouse and the children
ordinarily and as has been
mentioned that recovery is uncapped and
it's very Broad and it includes unlike
most States uh an element of Damages
known as hedonic damages which is loss
of the enjoyment of life of the decedent
so that the
recoveries in wrongful death cases are
significant right
now and as chairman has pointed out the
parent child and the spousal uh
Consortium claims are an add-on to the
made so our concerns and I think the
concerns that were raised by the
insurance department are not just what
are the consequences on premiums but uh
what are the consequences on
availability of insurance and I think
uhu um that was uh suggested by uh Mr
Bradley uh a concern of the hospital
Association and it is to us as well and
moreover New Hampshire and I'll conclude
with this New Hampshire is a state that
has a balanced system of Civil Justice
in our opinion and I think in the
opinion of of lawyers both plff and
defense lawyers it's a fair and balanced
system Our concern is not to disturb
that balance the benefit of a fair
system and one that's perceived as fair
is that it promotes
competition uh uh for in
Insurance uh it it encourages insurers
to write here and the result of that is
lower premiums and we enjoy lower
premiums overall than uh most other
states um so we're concerned about
sending a message if this bill were to
pass with these extraordinary increases
uh that it would uh uh it would uh be
detrimental to to that reputation and to
new hampture uh as being viewed as a
good environment in which to do business
so we we would oppose this bill but if
you do want to look at it we ask you to
be armed with the facts and then make
your policy judgment as to what in
approp
change if any would be thank you very
much Mr Russ uh questions for this
witness seeing none thank you sir thank
please good afternoon um Mr chair
members of the committee my name is Rob
Barry I'm general counsel to the New
Hampshire Division of Medicaid uh we are
here uh in a neutral capacity with this
bill but we did want to get um a point
out there for the committee's
consideration you've heard a lot of
testimony relative to Upward pressure on
premiums uh and the effect on the
potential provider Comm uh Community New
Hampshire Medicaid's primary concern is
ensuring that our members have access to
Quality Care particularly in underserved
areas um if this prediction were true
we're concerned about the effect of um
driving out current providers and
thereby resulting in fewer providers for
our member Community uh obviously this
is a very complicated issue um and I
leave it to the uh committee's best
judgment on that but we just wanted to
put this out there as a potential
consequence and I'm happy to take any
questions questions for this witness
seeing none thank you oh I'm sorry
representative men sorry thank thank you
thank you for taking my question um how
I'm not clear on how this would affect
Medicaid if there's an upward pressure
on the premiums as predicted by many
people here uh I know that's a source of
contention uh and I'm not here to
resolve that contention uh because that
is not my um my expertise but the
concern from Medicaid's perspective is
if that prediction does bow true that an
upward pressure on premiums leads to
Providers leaving the state results in
fewer providers for the Medicaid
community that's where we're
at right other questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
please thank you Mr chair members of the
committee for the the record my name is
Dave juv I'm a senior vice president
with the business and industry
Association we are a uh Statewide
Chamber of Commerce a membership
organization with over 400 employer
members and we are here on behalf of our
employers throughout the state we are
opposed to this bill I'd like to
primarily address a number of comments
that have been made in the testimony up
to now one of which chairman Lynn you
were asking um speculating why we would
have a cap at all when we don't cap any
other types of wrongful death Awards and
the answer to that question is it was a
result of legislative
compromise uh previous to 1997 there was
no loss of Consortium award in New
Hampshire at that time a bill was
brought forward to allow for that um one
side uh uh represented here today
supported that the other side
represented by many people here today
opposed it and the uh compromise that
was struck that both sides could live
with while not being uh necessarily
happy about was the cap of 150,000 for
loss of spouse and 50,000 for loss of
child uh previous witness talked about
the uh history of this specific Bill and
they noted correctly that the bill when
it was introduced was uh a removal of
all caps relating to loss of
Consortium um as you can imagine there
was strong opposition to that in the
Senate and uh the the uh witness
correctly said
that I can paraphrase that they would
have been happy with a cap of a million
which would mirror what we have in Maine
but the senate in their wisdom decided
to lower it to
500,000 for loss of spouse and 300 ,000
for loss of child want to make it clear
that was not a compromise that those
opposed to the bill could live with or
could support we did not support that
and most of us here today who are uh
oppos to that or or continue our
opposition um just one other quick bit
of information there was a previous
witness and and he was at the Senate
hearing too who uh felt it was important
to make sure that you clearly understood
that uh increasing this cap or removing
the cap entirely wouldn't affect workers
comp rates um I'm not an attorney but
I'll use an attorney that or I'll use a
phrase that attorneys use which is
stipulate we will stipulate that it
won't increase workers comp rates no one
has suggested it would I'm a little
mystified why he wants to continue to
point to that but it won't affect
workers comp rates it will I believe
affect other forms of Insurance
liability insurance or medical
malpractice insurance which is why we
oppose it now I mentioned the original
Law setting this up was a result of a
compromise and it was something that
both sides could live with if not
support one thing that hasn't come up in
in this hearing so far is well it this
amount hasn't been increased since 1996
s and shouldn't we we be looking at an
increase and for those on the committee
that are
uncomfortable killing the bill or
sending it to study but you're equally
uncomfortable on a dramatic increase
which is how the bill came over for the
Senate there is um a Middle Road um I
want to be clear Bia would support you
killing the bill or sending it to study
but the Middle Road that you might
consider
is what would this be today if it were
tied to the inflation rate and I looked
I used the uh Bureau of Labor Statistics
within the Federal Department of Labor
CPI calculator and found that the $150
,000 award in
1997 in current dollars would be worth
approximately
$294,000 and the
$50,000 award for loss of child or
parent in
$224 would be approximately
$98,000 and I think you'll see that's
well below what the Senate uh Bill set
those awards
at I'm not suggesting those opposed to
the bill would support that middle
ground I'm pretty sure that those
supporting the bill would also not to
support it but in many ways that would
equal what probably happened in 1996
which is uh the legislature came up with
a compromise recognizing that there's
strong opposition on both sides of the
issue happy to answer any questions if I
can questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
sir uh next I'm going to call Roger
Turon
please thank you Mr chairman thank you
Representatives um my name is Roger
Turon I live in DOA New Hampshire I've
been a trial lawyer specializing in
personal injury and death cases for
about 43 years I practice in Mass New
Hampshire and Maine been practicing in
New
Hampshire 1994 maybe so not quite the
whole 40 years I would love to be able
to rebut or comment on all of the
different issues that have been raised
in opposition to 462 um but I'm not
going to take your time it's been a long
day already I'll will try to limit
myself to taking and make making an
argument and making some issues from
sort of a satellite view level the macro
level as to this issue and then
something on a micro more personal level
on the macro level um you've heard
virtually all the talk today has been on
the issue of will this raise premiums
lots of Scare Tactics about pressure on
premiums and all that kind of stuff you
folks all know much better than I do
because you sit in these hearings all
the time that argument is made day in
day out on so many different bills so
many requests for immunity we want to be
able to do something but the insurance
will be so much we have to have immunity
from liability um all sorts of things
are considered it's going to put
pressure the insurance industry has more
data available to it than anybody else
in the world and yet somehow they always
can only talk about upward pressure
their customers are concerned that their
rates might go up and that might put
them out of business doctors are
concerned their premiums will go up
nobody ever talks about the data that
the insurance industry could bring to
bear on the issue if they chose
to and you kind of have to wonder why
maybe it's because the data doesn't
support the argument and they're better
off just scaring their insurance
customers into saying we're afraid
please protect us let me just give you a
practical real world argument as to why
you don't have to worry that this is
going to be a huge increase in premiums
it'll be tiny if any at
all these are wrongful death cases we're
talking about There is almost no such
thing as a wrongful death case that
isn't worth at least a million dollar
settlement can we agree on that I don't
think anybody would disagree loss of a
life whether it's an income earner or an
atome mom or a child it's there has to
be compensation of at least a million
dollars you know how many insurance
policies for liability that include
death and uh and injury you know how
many of those insurance policies are
worth more than a million dollars in
coverage almost
none I don't think in 45 years I've seen
more than one or two cases where there
was more than a million dollar insurance
policy they're usually with major
trucking companies they have good siiz
policies major manufacturers have
good-sized policies and I guess doctors
and hospitals have good siiz policies
but the vast vast majority of wrongful
death cases are going to settle for the
policy limit of a million dollar before
we even talk about loss of Consortium so
in those cases whether there's a cap
Consortium is totally irrelevant doesn't
raise anything there are however a few
cases like Holly Haynes mentioned one of
her own clients an at home mom who's a
caregiver to her kids doesn't work she's
killed instantly so so because she's
killed instantly there's no subjective
recovery for pain and suffering damages
because she's not a wage earner there's
no recovery for a lifetime of lost
income or the amount of that income she
would have shared with her family
literally the only recovery available to
that
person is well to the family of that
person is the loss of Consortium the
things mom would have done for me as I
was rais
the things my wife would have done for
me as a husband taking care of the
household
unless imagine in that situation your
entire recovery is
$150,000 for the loss of your wife and
50,000 uh and each of the kids getting
50,000 for the loss of
Mom we have talked exclusively about
what chairman Lynn talks about calls the
tail of the dog haven't heard much about
the dog and the dog we should be talking
about is what's
fair what's the right thing to do is it
fair for the family of that Mom who
doesn't work to be limited to a total of
what might be $200,000 in
recovery every time every time there's a
wrongful death actually every time
there's a serious injury there's going
to be some loss there's going to be
somebody's going to hurt monetarily
the question is where do we put that
hurt do we put it on the person who
caused it and perhaps on the insurance
company who just was agreeable to making
a huge profit in order to take the risk
on themselves like someone said you know
insurance is all about the premiums of
the many pay the costs of the few well
I'm afraid what they're lobbying for is
the premiums of the many pay for our
profit and only part of the loss of the
few that's what they're arguing for
so the question is where does the State
of New Hampshire come in on talking
about what's fair when we do these do we
want full recovery or do we not let me
throw it a ridiculous hypothetical let's
assume there's a wrongful death and the
only recovery will be loss of Consortium
it's it's not a whole lot but you know
this person's life was worth millions to
someone we've got a couple choices we
could make the wrongfully acting
defendant the negligent person pay for
it which means perhaps their insurance
company pays for it
what if the other option is well I know
to keep prices down to keep insurance
premiums down so we don't have doctors
leaving the state and we don't have
insurance companies choosing to do their
business elsewhere to keep it down let's
just do a lottery Whenever there a
wrongful death we'll pick a name out of
a hat some resident of the state and
we'll make them pay the millions of
dollars worth of damage that was caused
to that family obviously that's
preposterous but you know what we're
already doing it we're doing it because
the lottery winner or the lottery loser
has already been chosen she was chosen
when the negligent driver crashed into
her car and killed her she was chosen
when the manufacturer made something
that was defective and something blew up
and killed her instantly we have already
chosen the loser right now and the loser
who has to pay all is the person who
just happened to be the Unlucky
individual who got killed and her family
and this time we recognize that's what
we're really doing that's the equivalent
of drawing a lottery why not make it
that the person who did the bad thing
and the industry they're part of just
all share the cost it's part of the cost
of doing
business I I submit that's really what
we need to do we need to look at a fair
way of making sure these large harms and
losses for a very few individuals are
not stuck on those
individuals so let me look at it now on
the more personal level
micro level when I was driving up here I
called my best friend she's recently
divorced her husband moved to Florida
she has a 16-year-old at home who's
starting to have some you know bullying
picking on me type issues in high school
she has another daughter who's 21 who's
no help because she's got some mental
illness issues I just asked her I said
hey if you were killed in a car crash
tomorrow what do you think Kiki should
be able to sue for for damages to
replace your services as a
mom not your income assume that's taken
care of assume the mortgage is taken
care of the foods put on the table
everything is taken care of except your
momy things like giving her a shoulder
to cry on helping her through the tough
times teaching her how to be independent
and strong and able to take care of
herself teaching about her selfworth
teaching how to be kind Kinder than
necessary all those things you do for
how much do you think she should be able
to sue for she say well she's 16 I'm 45
at this point in my life it should be
Millions I said I agree do you know how
much you can sue for said the law right
now is
$50,000 I swear if I had been face to
face with her I would have seen her her
jaw drop she how is that possible who
says that I'll tell you who says that
the people in this room the people in
the State House the people in the state
house will tell her whether or not her
daughter could get more than $50,000 for
all of the things a mother does for her
child
I
suggest maybe you do a little of your
own little research not Actuarial very
personal very one-on-one level you all
have loved ones at home or grandchildren
spouses
children try asking one of them if I
died or if your mom was killed in a
crash tomorrow something like that
happened how much do you think you
should be able to recover for what
you're going to miss out on on Mom
a bet I know the answer is going to be a
whole lot more than
$50,000 it's going to be a whole lot
more than 150,000 on his
bouse thanks for listening questions for
this witness thank you sir questions for
this witness seeing none thank you very
much thank you um I don't have any other
pink cards is there anyone else who
wishes to testify on Senate Bill
462 seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing on that uh Bill and then I know
we're running very late and I apologize
for that but I'm going to open the
576 um
and
uh we do we have anybody here that wants
to
test
okay all right
um
so what uh where did she did she come in
and oh you want you want would you mind
coming oh okay all right great
right all right I'm opening the opening
the hearing on Senate Bill 576 and I
represent I recognize representative
Wallace thank you Mr chairman members of
the committee for the record uh this is
I'm represented Wallace Rockham County
District 8 the town of Danville and I'm
here to introduce Senate Bill 576
relative to reporting of death of Voters
on behalf of Senator abbis uh that being
said people behind me will answer any of
the questions about that and uh there we
are thank you very much representative
right now I'm going to call on uh Aon
[Laughter]
thank you thank you for for your yes
thank you for your my name is Aaron
Hennessy I am the deputy secretary of
state I don't usually come before this
committee most of my time is spent in
election law um and various other
committees in the house but I wanted to
talk to you about this bill because it
affects um your town clerks and um the
division of art art um Department um the
vital Record division
um I have some concerns away about the
way this is written just as um someone
who unfortunately had to be an executive
of a will um of of an estate um when my
mother recently passed away and I don't
understand how um one the executiv would
know that they needed to do this within
30 days um two who the clerk would be
that they're supposed to reach out to um
is it they're um the person who passed
away city or town clerk um or is it just
any clerk um and what if they don't do
this what would happen to them um right
now the way that um death notice are um
people are removed from the checklist
the voter checklist when someone passes
away is that the um Vital Records
database um is bumped up against the
Statewide voter registration database
and um matches are sent to your
supervisors of the checklist and and
they need to review those and if they
determine that it is a match then they
will remove that voter from the
checklist um sometimes there may be some
delays in this process because if a um
if the supervisors haven't met in a
month or so um then they won't be
removed that quickly also if for some
reason the person who passes away the
person who fills out the um death
certificate puts them as living um as
their address as being where they were
living with them most recently versus
where they may be registered to vote so
if I live in Littleton and somebody was
living with me before they passed away I
may have put my Littleton address as
their address versus where they may be
their voting um address may have been
someplace else and they just hadn't
voted in a while um I'm happy to take
questions on this I know this is not a
normal process that um election law
process that we talk about with this
committee but any questions you might
have I'm happy to answer
uh representative Horan and then
representative
Smith yes um how how common also this
way I read this bill well first of all
ret Dev vote is voluntary so I don't
understand these people but there are
some people who like say I don't want to
vote I don't want to encourage those
politicians so um what happens if when
one of those people's dies and then
there also course many people in the
state who are not citizens but still
when they die that has to be reported so
how how would the How would how would
that impact those situations like um how
would they even know like whether the
clerk needs to get an announcement for
those
people thank you for the question I am
not the sponsor of the bill so I think I
would putting out to answer that I was
follow up maybe this one maybe you can't
answer have
there course you're not responsib but
there been any allegations where a
recently deceased
were problems of people um voting um
voting any are there any allegations of
deceased people like um having their
votes recorded improperly because
somebody's impersonating them or for
whatever reasons those are actually a
problem here for this bill to solve in
your experience
or I don't know that there have been but
I think the AG might be able to answer
that
better representative
Smith thank you
um I've been trying to keep track of the
systems that are being used is there um
not a new system that is or a new effort
to coordinate systems that already
exists um in the Secretary of State's
office thank you for the question and if
I understand it correctly there is there
are already two systems that exist to do
this the um the nean system system is
the system that Vital Records uses for
death certificates birth certificates
marriage
certificates and some other things as
well um and then there's the Statewide
voter registration system it used um
we're calling it Statewide voter
registration system now because the new
one's rolling out and should go live
fairly soon and those two systems talk
to each other and that's how within the
Statewide voter registration system the
supervisors get notification when
somebody that is registered on their
checklist passes away is that is that
what you
asked yes yes it is and I guess I know
it's not your bill and you're you're
just here to talk about what you do
which is what I'm curious about does
that not mean that this is um a solution
problem thank you for the question um
you don't have to answer you know that
you know since you've sat on this side
of the table also you know you don't
have to answer that I don't know I think
there may be some instances where maybe
some
supervisors didn't meet timely
and from what I was told there may have
been an instance where somebody's name
was still on the checklist but that
person had passed
away um but had they
voted not that I know of
no so I repeat my question yeah you are
not aware of any need are you aware of
any need for this bill to be passed in
order to make sure that we have a more
um
accurate
uh record of who is voting thank you uh
necessary yes representative
thank you Mr chairman thanks for taking
my question
um with somebody who has passed away
their name still being on a voter
checklist um absent any notification
thereof would that not create the
potential for um misappropriation of an
absentee ballot by some method by an you
actor if for some reason say somebody's
name on the checklist is Robert um and
their name is noted on their the desri
is Bob with a different address then
those would not match up in our system
and there is the opportunity for that
person to still be on their local
checklist until the 10-year um automatic
Purge y um then um there is an
opportunity for a bad actor to illegally
request an absentee ballot in that
person's name um that ballot will go to
that person's address so that person
would have to be living at their address
um and also vote illegally but there are
a lot of
um things that would happen to that
person if they were to do that and I'm
not a lawyer and I've never been on
Judiciary one would hope yes
representative
Horgan well maybe I should saved this
for a theoretical work session but know
and know it's probably probably heard of
other incident incidents this uh Madam
SEC deputy secretary of state but in my
family actually the last conversation I
had with my mother who had a stroke a
few days before the N for primary where
she was assuring me that she had um
filled in her absentee ballot and
written and and uh like she told me who
she voted for and how she voted but
that's uh but um but in that case she
was alive when she requested the ballot
and live when she filled it out and she
was intending to still be alive on uh
January 23rd when the ballots were open
and counted but uh unforeseen
circumstances prevented that but
um I then but this bill probably doesn't
necessarily affect that in so far as
they might have stricken the name from
the checklist before the election day
but um actually do you have any data on
how often that happens if somebody
legitimately fills on absentee ballot
and then not dies before the uh date of
the election thank you for the question
I may be able to get data on that that
what would happen in that instance where
um if somebody knew that that person had
passed away the absentee ballot would be
rejected and um the reason written on it
would be because um the voter was
deceased and then um later when it goes
into the Statewide voter registration
system to document the reason why that
ballot was rejected that would be the
reason in there um I think our new
system will have a lot better um
reporting mechanisms to actually get
that data for you but that unfortunately
does happen quite often yeah I know I
can answer that like and I know like
years ago when I was uh working at the
polls in Durham the moderator not the
current moderator but previous one um we
got we actually that question arose we
got in a absente B for particular
individuals prominent person in town and
we said um should we count this you know
like uh so and so is dead and actually
the moderator gave what was a very uh
very very amusing answer that lightened
the mood although it was incorrect was
says like well Was he alive at the time
when he filled out the ballot and we
said well as far as we can tell judging
by yes he said then we should count it
which certainly emotionally feels like
the right thing to do even though that
was probably not what the RSA actually
said about it but
thank all right uh representative Manos
thank you thank you for taking my
question um I'm just wondering about New
Hampshire residents who die out of state
and how the vital statistics system
interacts with the voter system thank
you for the question um I believe for
Most states and sometimes there's gaps
in there um those States would um send
notify our state um usually it's just in
paper copies of of death notices and
then our Vital Records Department inputs
that information into our Vital Records
database and um then that matches up
with our Statewide voter registration
database and then your supervisor would
representative trip thank you chair um
I'm going have to show my ignorance here
because uh I
haven't ever requested an absente ballot
so I don't know uh can you request a
absentee
mail uh you can request an absentee
ballot via the mail
follow up y well then uh is there some
sort of uh protocol that ensures that
someone who requests a absentee ballot
by mail is the person who's going to be
voting um thank you for the question um
when you request an a an absentee ballot
you have to sign that um you are the
person requesting the absentee ballot um
as well is when you return your absentee
ballot um on the affidavit envelope you
are signing that you are the voter that
is voting with that unless um someone
has assisted you which is legal um in
filling out that um ballot because
you're unable to fill it out yourself so
there was there's many times that you
are attesting that you are that person
um and when you do that ATT attestation
if you're lying you're breaking a law
and sorry I don't have I didn't bring my
election law book was made to give you
the
statutes other questions so I guess I I
have and I and I apologize because I you
may have answered this already and and I
wasn't paying attention and I apologize
for that but when it says in the part of
the bill that's not not subject to the
amendment Whenever there is filed in the
office of the clerk an official notice
of the death of any person over 18 so my
question is does
somebody does does somebody have an
obligation to give the clerk that notice
in other words is there somebody if if I
die today does does some does my wife
does somebody have an obligation to
notify the clerk that I
died thank you for the question Mr
chairman um no the you you you do not
have the obligation the um the clerk
will know because through the death
certificate process that will be in the
vital record database that they they
have access
to but so okay so I died by the there's
a death certificate it goes to the vital
records the does does the clerk then
have an obligation to check the vital
records
every you know and if so how often do
that are you asking is the clerk have
responsibilities to update the voter
checklist based on that
information well in other words does
does it does the clerk have some
obligation to to access the death
certificates and say okay you know like
once a year once every three years once
do they have any obligation to do that
or can a clerk just not do
that so the only instances that the that
I know of that the clerk would need to
do that is if the supervisors have asked
them to do it to run they can run a
report of um voters who have passed away
in their town they have only have access
to their Town um in V records
information um and the supervisors can
use that to make sure that the matching
system caught everyone and there were no
like Bobs or Roberts that slips through
in the matching of the database but
other than that it's not the clerk's
responsibility now sometimes it is in
cities but most of the time we're
talking about supervisors of the
checklist who have the obligation to
update update the checklist
so that
so and so the supervisor's obligation to
up to update the checklist includes
checking the death the notices of death
correct okay all
right okay all right thank you very much
oh yes representative Andress sorry
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my
question I'm not up on the law what
clerks can do do you know what Authority
we allow the clerks that they can change
a name on there like if I go in and say
so and so his moved
away don't no longer lives in my house
like they pass away can they take that
name off or what what law allows them to
make changes are you asking to take them
name off the checklist or put in that
they've passed away take a name off the
checklist no um anytime a name is
removed from the checklist has to be in
an open session of the
supervisors um of the checklist who are
elected election officials and they have
to do that in public session um which is
noticed and they will note in the
checklist and the checklist is also
before you go to vote um when you go
into your clerks the checklist should be
there in their office if you want to
ever look at at
it oh yes representa I just wanted to
supervisors what notices are they
allowed to
accept to take names off the
checklist that make sense yeah it does
I'm just wondering do you want are we
talking about death what this bill talks
about okay so for someone who is passed
away they are allowed to without sending
a 30-day notice to the voter if if when
they go into the system and they the
Statewide voter registration system and
they've got the list from the match that
says this voter has passed away and they
look at the two system information yes
that's correct that person
matches they can click off and that
person will be removed from the
checklist and it'll be in their minutes
um the um the the supervisors may also
request the clerk to run a report for
them from the system just in case the
match didn't catch somebody who may have
passed away because um they used a
different name on the death certificate
than is on the checklist for example if
your middle name is Aaron and your first
name is Katherine and you go by Aaron
but the death certificate says Katherine
and some somehow sometimes names don't
match
up yeah so I have one other question if
we um if we were to amend this I mean I
understand the the the argument that
maybe this isn't sort of strictly
necessary on the other hand it does seem
like it would help to provide another
level of assurance and what I'm
wondering is if we were to amend this
bill to put in some language that said
something like um the uh judicial branch
shall provide
uh uh on shall provide notice on on a
form by which an
estate uh is is initially opened of the
obligation of the ex executive or
personal representative to provide the
notice to the clerk um that would that
would sort of presumably would help to
provide to ensure that somebody who is
appointed executive administrator knows
that they have that
obligation is that I mean is that seem
reason well if to open in the state um
or personal representative I mean you
would have to you'd have to go to the
Probate Court would you not no because
think I'm not a lawyer and I don't even
play one on TV but whether you would
have to go to Probate Court would depend
upon on the value of of the if a very
small level well doesn't have to be very
small truthfully um and uh for example
if if everything goes to the
spouse period the end you don't have to
go to
probate um and
uh uh somebody has to have filed a death
certificate and it's not going to be the
person who died that's the only thing I
know it's going to be somebody else and
but that doesn't have anything to do
with the courts and um if everything's
happening in the same town the death
certificate's going to
be
basically issued through the town or
um sure yes representative Wallace thank
you um having just gone through this a
couple of weeks ago on Easter the way it
worked presently is once someone passes
okay whoever the Undertaker is uh this
happened at home so the funeral parlor
files the death certificate with the
Bureau of Vital Statistics and that can
be acquired at any town in any
municipality in the state so the last
thing I want to be doing is having the
family member or the surviving uh family
member doing all this paperwork so I do
believe it is already automatically done
and filed by the funeral par that's as
of three four weeks ago and my personal
experience if that
helps and all the copies we get are at
the Town Hall so I would think there'd
connection all right other questions for
this witness seeing none thank you very
you no it's not but my mother-in-law is
Katherine Aaron Hennessy and she goes by
anyone else who wishes to testify on
Senate Bill
576 seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing on Senate Bill 576 and I think
adjourn
e